Herzlich Willkommen beim Rasenfunk. Das hier ist das Tribünengespräch, in dem wir uns eine Sendung lang mit einem Thema aus dem Bereich des Fußballs befassen. Mein Name ist Max Ost und bei mir ist Jonathan Sachse einer der besten Journalisten im Bereich Fußballdoping. Und das soll unser heutiges Thema sein. Hallo Jonathan.
Hallo, ich freue mich sehr, dass ich mit dir heute da ur sprechen darf.
Ich mich erst. Jonathan, es hat ganz, ganz viele Gründe, warum ich dich als mein Gesprächspartner ausgewählt habe, denn du bist einer der am besten informierten Journalisten im Land zum Thema Doping im Fußball. Magst du uns mal kurz erzählen, was du so gemacht hast und wie du zu dem Thema gekommen bist?
Ja, kann ich gerne machen. Genau, also vielleicht zwei verschiedene Sachen. Einmal der Weg, wie ich jetzt zum Doping gekommen bin. Ich habe die letzten fünf Jahre ungefähr als freiberuflicher Journalist gearbeitet und habe mich schon immer sehr für das Thema Doping interessiert. Und habe damit klassisch mit dem Radsport begonnen. Ich bin die letzten drei Jahre zum Beispiel zu Tour de France gefahren und habe da versucht, ein paar Hintergrundstücke auch zum Thema Doping zu recherchieren. Und mit der Zeit fand ich das Thema Radsport immer weniger interessant. Warum? Also nicht unbedingt, weil mich der Radsport wenig interessiert hat, sondern weil ich das nicht fand, dass es ein besonderes Gleichgewicht zwischen den Sportarten gibt. Also ich habe irgendwann Daniel Drepper kennengelernt, der die Seite Fußballdoping auch ins Leben gerufen hat, 2011. Und wir haben uns immer schon öfter darüber unterhalten und auch schon einige Geschichten zusammen gemacht. Und so gab es bei mir dann so einen sanften Übergang von sehr auf Radsport fokussiert hin zu anderen Sportarten und mittlerweile sehr auf Fußball konzentriert bei der ganzen Thematik. Und ich hatte am Anfang ein paar Gastbeiträge bei Daniel mal geschrieben, bei Fußballdoping.de und dann Ende 2012 vielleicht, habe ich dann als regelmäßiger Autor angefangen. Und mittlerweile sind Daniel und ich feste Kollegen seit dem letzten Sommer, arbeiten beide für das gemeinnützige Recherchenbüro Korrektiv und haben in Korrektiv sozusagen die Seite Fußballdoping.de dann auch mit reingenommen und haben dadurch auch nochmal andere Möglichkeiten, jetzt das Thema anzugehen als vorher.
Magst du noch kurz was über die Seite Fußballdoping.de erzählen, die jetzt bestimmt von all unseren Hörern angesorgt wird, sobald sie in Nähe eines Browsers sind?
Ja, ich bin vor allem gespannt, wie mobilkompatibel unsere Seite mittlerweile ist. Ich glaube, wir müssen noch was ändern. Ich stelle mir gerade so vor, wie Leute in der Bahn Fußballdoping.de versuchen anzuwählen. Also Fußballdoping.de, die URL haben wir jetzt schon fünfmal genannt, ist eine Seite, wo wir einen ganz eindeutigen, monothematischen Schwerpunkt setzen. Wir finden das bei dem Thema total sinnvoll, weil wir dadurch die Möglichkeit haben, immer mehr in die Tiefe zu gehen bei dem Thema. Das war sozusagen Daniels Ursprungsgedanke damals. Es wird noch zu wenig zum Thema berichtet und wenn dann auch immer mal wieder ganz unterschiedliche Orte im Netz oder sonst wo irgendwo in den Medien. Und es würde sich doch lohnen, einfach da mal tiefer einzusteigen, auch so ein paar ganz grundsätzliche Sachen zu regeln und Fragen zu beantworten, wie zum Beispiel wird eigentlich im Fußball gedobt und da einen Ort zu haben, wo man auch nicht immer wieder bei Null beginnen muss. Und deswegen ging es da los. Mittlerweile, gut drei Jahre später, haben wir vielleicht so 100 Artikel dort veröffentlicht. Wir versuchen auch, mehrere Artikel ins Englische zu übersetzen, um einfach die Zielgruppe zu erweitern. Gerade, wenn Themen irgendwie Europa oder noch internationaler Zielgruppen betreffen. Und nebenbei betreiben wir dann Facebook und besonders Twitter sehr intensiv, wo wir sehr viel auch irgendwelche Links teilen. Oder uns werden Links zugetragen zum Thema Interview mit dem. Da gibt es einen netten Kommentar. Da hat jemand einfach nur in einem Nebensatz, sozusagen in einem Artikel was zum Thema Doping gesagt ist. Da wird alles gesammelt. Und jetzt gibt es auch ein Newsletter. Wer sich da interessiert, kann sich da auch eintragen. Da wird jetzt die erste Version erst verschickt. Kleine Anekdote dazu. Wir hatten das Newsletter-System schon vor zwei Jahren, glaube ich, eingebaut. Wir haben aber nie ein Newsletter verschickt, weil wir immer dachten, das funktioniert nicht. Wir haben jetzt erst entdeckt, dass da mittlerweile 300 Leute eingetragen sind, die tatsächlich auch gespeichert wurden. Und da wir bei Corrective jetzt ein neues Newsletter-System haben, wo alles ein bisschen einfacher geht, konnten wir die Leute dann integrieren. Es waren vielleicht ein paar Leute überrascht, als sie gestern plötzlich von Fußballdoping in der E-Mail bekommen haben. Es hat auch nur einer die E-Mail als Spam zurückgemeldet.
Das ist eine gute Quote.
Ja, keine Ahnung, wie viele es gelesen haben. Genau, deswegen gibt es Fußballdoping. Vielleicht noch einen Satz dazu. Eine Sache, die wir uns immer gewünscht haben und die mittlerweile auch ganz gut funktioniert ist, dass wenn wir uns sehr auf das Thema fokussieren und uns da auch mit den Jahren als Experten beweisen können, dass wir auch mehr Rücklauf bekommen von Leuten, die tatsächlich mit Doping in irgendeiner Form in Berührung gekommen sind. Das war schon ein strategischer Gedanke und mittlerweile funktioniert das auch ganz gut. Das merken wir gerade, wenn es Berichterstattungswellen gibt, wie es gerade in den Tagen auch zum Thema Fußballdoping der Fall ist, dass wir da Leute einfach auf unsere Seite gehen, die vorher noch nicht drauf waren, die uns dann auch mal kontaktieren. Wir hatten jetzt gerade diese Tage jemanden, der aus Baden-Württemberg kommt, bis in Stuttgart kennt, früher da in den unteren Juniorenmannschaften geklickt hat und uns da einiges zugeschrieben hat. So bauen sich relativ leicht Kontakte auf, auch aus Leuten aus dem inneren Kreis, kann man glaube ich sagen. Der inneren Kreis ist zwar relativ groß im Fußball, weil es einfach viele Menschen gibt, die da aktiv sind, aber das sind die Leute, mit denen man sprechen möchte, die selbst irgendeiner Form denken, hier gibt es einen Missstand, da möchte ich darüber sprechen und da suche ich mir die Leute, wo ich denke, die hauen jetzt nicht nur irgendwie schnell was raus, sondern mit denen kann ich vernünftig darüber reden.
Das heißt, ihr seid schon sehr tief im Thema drin und grabt euch jetzt automatisch immer noch tiefer rein. Dann lass uns doch auch mal thematisch beginnen, auf die aktuellen Vorfälle kommen wir später noch. Du hast gesagt, als du beschrieben hast, wie du zum Thema Fußballdoping gekommen bist, dass es einen Ungleichgewicht gibt zwischen jetzt zum Beispiel Tour de France-Berichterstattung und Fußball. Ich vermute, dass du damit darauf anspielst, dass man gefühlt, also ich als Außenstehender, habe das Gefühl, wenn man bei der Tour de France als Zuschauer ist, muss man aufpassen, dass man nicht auf Spritzen tritt, weil das im Prinzip Apotheken auf zwei Rädern sind. Und im Bereich Fußballdoping ist das erste Argument ja immer, Doping bringt im Fußball ja gar nichts. Und da würde ich jetzt mal vermuten, deine Antwort ist, doch, es bringt was.
Ja, und man kann im Fußball sogar viel kreativer werden, im Doping als im Radsport der Fall ist. Da gibt es auch sehr, sehr kreative Methoden im Radsport, aber ich glaube, im Fußball hast du einfach, dadurch, dass es eine sehr komplexe, also auch für den Körper komplexe Sportart ist. Ich meine, damit nicht nur das alte Argument, da spielt vor allem die Taktik eine Rolle, und wie ich technisch so drauf bin. Aber auch für den Körper ist das grundsätzlich extrem komplex. Das heißt, du musst schnell sprinten können, immer wieder in mehreren Situationen spielen. Also wenn ich jetzt an einen Spieler denke wie Ubo Mojang bei Dortmund, der legt bestimmt seine 20-30 Sprints in einem Spiel hin. Dann hast du die Ausdauerfähigkeiten. Du hast grundsätzlich das Problem wie ein Nebensport, du bist verletzt und möchtest danach möglichst schnell wieder auf dem Platz stehen. Deine Muskelkraft spielt eine Rolle, gerade wenn du ein junger Spieler bist und versuchst dich schnell oben mitzutablieren oder du kommst aus einem Ausland, wo es vielleicht körperlich nicht ganz so robust war, wie in der Bundesliga oder Premier League oder sonst wo. Und so gibt es eigentlich relativ viele Faktoren, wo es natürlich auch auf dem ganz natürlichen und legalen Weg probiert wird, das Maximale auszureizen. Aber da sind wir mittlerweile relativ weit. Also klar kann man da immer noch einen Schritt weiter gehen, die Technik verbessert sich auch immer im medizinischen Bereich. Aber irgendwann bist du da an der Grenze und wenn du da den nächsten Schritt gehen willst, dann funktioniert das über Doping.
Diese Bereiche schließen sich auch nicht gegenseitig aus. Also du hast jetzt unter anderem genannt Explosivität, viele Sprints, dann Kraft. Das liegt natürlich nahe und Rehabilitation nach Verletzung ist dann wahrscheinlich ein eigener Bereich, zu dem wir auch noch kommen. Aber das schließt sich jetzt auch nicht aus, dass ich quasi Doping verwenden könnte, um meine Explosivität zu erhöhen, ohne damit der Ausdauer zu schaden.
Ja, also natürlich kann ich mich auch falsch durpen, sodass es absolut ineffektiv ist. Aber das ist nicht dieses einfache Spielchen. Ich baue mir Muskeln auf und dann laufe ich langsamer. Also das sieht man ja auch. Ich finde, da ist das beste Beispiel der 100-Meter-Sprint, wo echte Muskelpakete gegeneinander versuchen, innerhalb von zehn Sekunden als erstes über die Zielinie zu rennen. Er ist vielleicht der Einzige, der zuletzt eine andere Figur gemacht hat, aber sonst sind das echt aufgepumpte Jungs, die ja gegeneinander rennen. Und ich nehme mir Ronaldo, auch ein extrem schneller Spieler, der ordentlich was am Oberkörper hat. Dieses Argument hat mir zuletzt öfter gehört, wird auch immer wieder gern genommen, aber das macht aus meiner Sicht überhaupt keinen Sinn. Wenn man intelligent dobt, dann spielt das absolut keine Rolle.
Und da hätte ich jetzt ja als erstes Argument gebracht, die 100-Meter-Sprinter sind alle Muskelpakete, aber ein 10.000 Meter Läufer dagegen sieht aus wie Dieter Baumann halt. Aber man kann das trotzdem miteinander verwirken.
Ja, finde ich schon, weil ja auch unterschiedliche Spielertypen gefragt sind. Es macht keinen Sinn, dass jeder ein Muskelpaket ist auf dem Platz. Also auch wenn Tim Wiese im Tor gerade gegen Ende anders aussah, aber der Torwart muss vielleicht nicht so extrem bewusst sein. Das bringt ihm nur was, wenn er zwischendurch im Strafraum hochgeht und sich ein bisschen besser durchsetzen will. Aber sonst braucht er kein Muskelpaket sein. Da macht es schon Sinn, dass er andere Fähigkeiten maximiert. Wenn ich einen Spieler habe, der die meisten Zweikämpfe auf dem Platz bestreitet, dann dafür vielleicht aber nicht die extremen Sprints hinlegen muss, weil er nicht außen spielt oder ganz vorne, dann macht es wieder mehr Sinn, dass ich meine Muskelbereiche optimiere oder einfach eine gute Ausdauerfähigkeit habe. Das muss man wirklich von Spielertyp zu Spielertyp unterscheiden. Und dann ist es auch immer am Abwägen. Wir müssen uns ja nur gucken, was grundsätzlich für unterschiedliche Spielertypen gab. Also Ailton zum Beispiel ist ja auch so.
Ailton war gedoppt?
Das kann sein, keine Ahnung. Sag nichts Falsches. Nicht, dass sich irgendwer es hört und dann Lust auf Klagen hat. Das wollte ich nicht damit sagen, aber es ist nur ein Beispiel, wie unterschiedlich körperlich die Fußballer, selbst die Profis, auf dem Platz unterwegs sind.
Und jetzt ist es aber so, dass man schon, du hast gesagt, man könnte clever dopen. Jetzt einfach mal vollkommen dahingestellt, ob das auch jemand tut. Das hört sich für mich so ein bisschen an, als gäbe es quasi so einen medizinischen Baukasten und je nachdem, in welche Schublade ich greife, diese Zusatzfähigkeit bekomme. Also fast so, als würde ich mein Auto in irgendeinem Gaming-Spiel tunen. Gibt es Mittel, die helfen mir, meine Sprints schneller anzuziehen? Es gibt Mittel, die helfen mir, meine Kraft, meine Ausdauer zu verstärken? Gibt es noch weitere? Reaktionsschnelligkeit ist das noch ein Thema?
Ja, guter Punkt. Genau, den hatten wir noch gar nicht genannt. Auf jeden Fall. Man muss ein bisschen schauen, was man mit seinem Körper anstellen möchte. Und wie man generell überhaupt drauf ist, so Zeug zu schlucken. Ich glaube, es gibt viele Profis – wir werden bestimmt heute noch über Schmerzmittel reden – die sind einfach daran gewohnt, viel Zeug an sich reinzuhauen, auch wenn sie vielleicht gar keine Schmerzen verspüren. Dann ist der Schritt ein bisschen einfacher, sich noch eine nächste Pille reinzuholen oder da noch etwas zu verpassen. Aber ich glaube, sonst die Grundparameter – ich versuche, die gerade auch nochmal durchzugehen – also Reaktionen, Ausdauersprints ist nochmal eine extra Sache, Muskeln, einmal Muskeln für die konkrete Zweikampfsituation, aber auch der Muskelaufbau nach Verletzungen ist extrem wichtig, dass der Körper einfach schnell wieder zu seiner alten Leistungsfähigkeit kommt. Das sind glaube ich so die Grundparameter.
Und vielleicht im Jugendbereich noch sowas wie Wachstumshormone zählt. Das zählt ja auch als Doping, außer man ist Ionin-Messi, oder sehe ich das falsch? Genau, klar.
Das Beispiel ist total triffend. Also wenn dein Körper eine grundsätzliche Veranlagung hat, wo du Defizite hast am Leuten gegenüber, kannst du natürlich da auch Wege schaffen, um das aufzuholen. Messi hat das bekommen, indem er für ihn einen medizinischen Freibrief bekommen hat, sozusagen eine Ausnahmegenehmigung, und sich lange auf jeden Fall einer Hormonbehandlung unterziehen konnte. Das war damals, soweit ich die Geschichte richtig verstanden habe, auch der Deal. Der Vater von Messi wollte ja scheinbar, ich brauche jemand, der mir diese Hormonbehandlung bei meinem Sohn zusichert. Da haben wir mit Baslunar einen geeigneten Partner gefunden. Und so konnte er das jahrelang machen, macht es vielleicht immer noch. Das weiß ich nicht, da wird ja nicht mehr offen drüber gesprochen. Es gab zwischendurch mal Berichte, dass bei Xavi dasselbe Spielchen ist. Baslunar versucht dann auch wieder schnell, Leben zu argumentieren. Aber du kannst natürlich auch grundsätzliche körperliche Defizite versuchen aufzuholen.
Das heißt quasi, dieses Argument, Doping bringt im Fußball gar nichts, ist eigentlich relativ leicht zu widerlegen, weil man eben sagen kann, es gibt ganz viele Bereiche, für die es auch entsprechende Dopingmethoden gibt. Und wenn man die clever anwendet, anwenden würde, dann würde das auch zur Leistungssteigerung bringen.
Ja, absolut. Und dazu kommt noch der große Punkt einfach, dass viel, das klingt immer so nach dem stumpfen Argument, aber ich finde das extrem wichtig, dass es einfach um eine Menge Kohle bei der ganzen Sache geht. Und Menge Kohle heißt im Sport einfach, du musst der Beste sein in deinem Bereich. Wenn du eine Chance haben willst, da mitzumischen. Und Menge Kohle heißt auch, es wird das Maximum für dich als Sportler getan. Ob das gesundheitlich für dich das Beste ist, aber du kommst überall an deine Grenzen und die Leute, von denen du umgeben wirst, deine Vertrauenspersonen, in allen möglichen Bereichen, können wir gerne noch mal detailliert darüber sprechen, finde ich ein sehr wichtiger Faktor. Die werden dir auch bestimmte, dir dazu raten, das Maximum aus der Ost zu holen. Und dazu noch, und Menge Kohle heißt auch, dass der Sport in der Lage ist, bestimmte Dinge unter den Tisch zu kehren, indem man sich da Wege schafft und Einflüsse nimmt an verschiedenen Stellen, sodass du eine ganz andere Kommunikationskraft hast und eine Kontrollkraft als in einer anderen Sportart. Beim Radsport ist es – ich bin ja gar nicht so ein großer Fan von dem Vergleich. Manchmal ziehe ich den auch immer automatisch, aber Radsport hat nicht die finanzielle Kraft. Das hat schon einen Grund, warum im Radsport alles so hintereinander explodiert ist und irgendwann das richtig eingebrochen ist. Das hat ja lange gehalten, aber spätestens seit 2006 konnte dann auch der Verband nichts mehr machen, auch wenn er es jetzt gerade wieder versucht.
Okay, das heißt, wir haben im Prinzip zwei Punkte schon angesprochen. Zum einen, es gäbe eine Notwendigkeit, also eine gewisse Drucksituation, die zumindest einen dazu bringen könnte, seine Leistung auch illegal zu steigern. Und zum zweiten, es gibt auf jeden Fall genügend Methoden, wie man Doping auch im Fußball gewinnbringend einsetzen kann. Gut, und dann ist natürlich die Frage, okay, das kann man so hinnehmen. Man könnte dopen und jetzt ist die Frage, ja, wird denn auch gedopt? Und da scheint es so ein bisschen einen Bias zu geben, meiner Meinung nach, zwischen öffentlicher Wahrnehmung und auch dem, was über die Medien transportiert wird. Und wie sie das tun, da reden wir vielleicht später nochmal kurz drüber. Und der Expertenwahrnehmung, die du jetzt eben hast. Also es gibt eben schon gar nicht so wenige Fälle, in denen Fußballdoping nachgewiesen wurde. Lass uns mal so ein bisschen die Geschichte des Fußballdopings so in kurzen Pfeilern vielleicht mal durchgehen, um einfach den euren Eindruck zu vermitteln, was da eigentlich schon alles passiert ist in dem Bereich. Ich denke, einer der populärsten ersten Fälle, vor allem aus Sicht eines Deutschen, ist die WM 1954 mit den Spritzen, die in der Kabine der deutschen Nationalmannschaft gefunden wurden. Wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, war die offizielle Variante, dass darin Vitamin C gespritzt wurde, stimmt das?
Genau, das war die Argumentation damals. Dann gab es verschiedene Wissenschaftler, die sich daran probiert haben. Besonders einer, Erik Eggers, der sich intensiv damit auseinandergesetzt hat. Ich überlege gerade, ob ich es noch in Erinnerung habe, aber seine Argumentation war, dass es nach dem WM-Sieg viele Gelbsuchtfälle gab bei den Nationalspielern. Das war sehr auffällig. Das konnte mehrere Faktoren haben. Es könnten verunreinigte Spritzen waren. Aber es gab wohl auch einigartige Ansätze und auch Belege – in Dokumenten habe ich das Bericht in Erinnerung – dass die Spieler mit Pervitin gedroht waren. Das ist so eine alte Droh- oder Aufputschmittel, die noch aus Kriegszeiten kommen. Seitdem Eric Eggers und andere sich daran getraut haben, gibt es diese Belege, was auch ein typischer Weg ist. Wir reden gleich über mehrere Fälle. Aber wenn man schaut, wie überhaupt so etwas rauskommt, sind es ja auch die Wissenschaftler, die das im Nachhinein herausfinden, sich genauer Dokumente beschaffen von damals, wo dann irgendwelche medizinischen Gutachten drin stehen oder Zeitzeugen finden, die anders nochmal genau erklären. Aber im Prinzip ist 54 der Startschuss. Wenn man den deutschen Fokus sieht, wo man über die ersten populären deutschen Dopingfälle sprechen kann, unsere erste Weltmeisterschaft.
Gleich der erste Titel steht im Schatten. Wenn du jetzt sagst, es gibt Belege, von was sprechen wir da und warum habe ich als erstes immer noch Wunder von Bern im Kopf und nicht wir haben die armen Ungarn ganz schön über den Tisch gezogen, illegal.
Ja, ich denke auch eher an das WM-Finale und den goldenen Schuss aus der zweiten Reihe. Aber das ist glaube ich nochmal so ein Grundsatzthema im Fußball. Du hast ja, dadurch, dass du eine Mannschaft Sportart hast, das akzeptiert man glaube ich viel schneller als Zuschauer, wenn einzelne Spieler über ihre natürliche Leistungsfähigkeit hinausgehen. Wenn wir das vergleichen mit Ausdauersportarten oder Sportarten, die sehr auf einen Sportler fokussiert sind, wo man sich sehr an einem dem Helden orientiert. Und dann rauskommt, der Spieler war gedobt, ist die Fallhöhe glaube ich auch einfach viel tiefer. Der eine Typ, dem du dahergefolgt bist, der ist halt weg im Fußball. Du lässt dich ja auch von anderen Sachen begeistern als Zuschauer. Natürlich zieht dich irgendwie das Tempo mit und all die Fähigkeiten, die dann letztendlich eine Rolle spielen, aber du lässt dich ja grundsätzlich erstmal dafür begeistern, weil viele Spieler gut mit einem anderen Fußball spielen. Ob dann da zwei gedobt waren, das klingt dann nicht schön danach, aber am Ende bleibt glaube ich eher das Spiel im Kopf.
Aber um das klarzumachen, es gibt eindeutige wissenschaftliche Belege, dass das das Parvettin eingesetzt wurde.
Das ist unzündlich. Wer das jetzt vertiefen möchte, kann wirklich mal auf unserer Seite schauen, da gibt es ein langes Interview mit Eric Eggers. Das war glaube ich eins unserer ersten Artikel, wo er genau nochmal erklärt, wie er auf welche Dokumente gekommen ist. Ich habe das im Detail auch nicht mehr am Kopf, aber er ist wirklich ein vernünftiger Wissenschaftler, der sich lange damit auseinandergesetzt hat und dafür Belege gefunden hat. Ich war ja noch im Kopf, dass er eine alte Dissertation damals aus Freiburg sogar nochmal zum Thema gefunden hat, wo genau das nochmal erforscht wurde und solche Sachen. Ja, ist lange her. An der Stelle muss ich passen mit den Originaldokumenten, die haben jetzt auch nicht mehr im Kopf geworden, als ich da langgehandelt habe.
Du kannst jetzt nicht jeden Beleg bis zu Ende führen, aber es reicht ja vielleicht zu wissen, dass ein renommierter Experte das schon mal nachgewiesen hat. Und wer sich dafür näher interessiert, der findet ja auf eurer Seite alle Infos. Gut, jetzt haben wir 54 entmystifiziert. Nationale Schande über uns zwei. Wie ging es denn weiter? Was sind so die nächsten Eckpfeiler im Bereich des Fußballdopings?
Ja, im Prinzip kann man glaube ich sagen, dass es in jedem Jahrzehnt schon Fälle gab, über die irgendwie gesprochen wurde. In den 60ern, also 66, gab es aus meiner Sicht, das ist kein Fall, sondern das Gegenteil. Die ersten Dopingkontrollen sogar war bei einer Weltmeisterschaft. Also rein auf internationaler Ebene von der FIFA. Und ich weiß auch nicht genau, wie dort getestet wurde. Ich erinnere mich nur an ein altes Interview, das ich mal mit Beckenbauer gelesen hatte, wo er irgendwie erwähnt, dass es da mal eine Kontrolle gab, das auch nicht mehr so richtig dokumentiert. Und es gab in den 60ern auch Fälle. Dann wäre allerdings nicht den prominenten Fall, den ich jetzt nennen kann. Aber wenn wir dann das Jahrzehnt weiter spinnen, dann haben wir mehrere. Da gibt es mehrere Sachen, die man diskutieren könnte. Das Letzte ist jetzt einfach das Aktuelle sozusagen, was jetzt über die Untersuchungskommission aus Freiburg bekannt geworden ist. Die Vorwürfe, dass in den 70ern und bis in die 80er hinein Nationalspieler, sage ich schon Vereinsspieler von Stuttgart und Freiburg mit einer Bolika versorgt wurden. Da gab es immer mal wieder schon ähnliche Ansätze und Verdachtsfälle in der Vergangenheit. Und ziemlich dahinter kommt dann Toni Schumacher schon, der mit seinem Buch Anpfiff später das beöffentlicht hat, aber das bezieht sich auf eine Zeit, die dann irgendwann – ich weiß nicht genau, wann Toni Schumachers Karriere begonnen hat, aber irgendwann ging das ja dann in die 80er oder Richtung 90er. Nur aus 89 kam, glaube ich, 89 sein Buch aus, Anpfiff. Ich weiß nicht, ob das die Zuhörer alle kennen, aber das war sozusagen das erste Enthüllungsbuch zum Thema Doping damals, dass wirklich jemand aus dem Inneren, prominente Figur, auch immer noch aktiv in der Nationalmannschaft, in einer guten Position – ich glaube, er war noch Stammkeeper zu dem Zeitpunkt sogar. Ja, hast du das noch in Erinnerung? Genau. Und offen darüber gesprochen hat, über medizinischen Missbrauch sozusagen. Und danach hat er seinen Platz verloren und musste, glaube ich, auch aus Köln damals wegwechseln. Wenn ich das noch in Erinnerung habe, findet man aber ziemlich viel im Netz zu.
Also 1987 kam er raus und danach war er seinen Stammplatz los.
Ah ja, okay, genau. Das war im Prinzip der erste große Wisseblower zum Thema Doping im Fußball. Jedenfalls auf deutscher Ebene, da gab es andere, der neustimt auch noch andere Typen. Ja, und danach kamen immer mehr Einschläge. Das lag auch daran, dass dann irgendwann die Dopingkontrollen losgingen. Ich glaube, 1988 gab es die erste in Deutschland.
Also die nationalen, meinst du? Weil von der WM haben wir ja schon darüber gesprochen, dass es schon welche gab.
Genau, ich meine die nationalen.
In der Bundesliga dann?
Genau, die aus der Bundesliga. Ich glaube, die gingen 1988 los, die ersten vereinzelten Wettkampfkontrollen. Aber noch mal deutlich später kamen dann die Trainingskontrollen dazu. Und dann ging es in den 90ern auch los, dann gibt es den nächsten ganz prominenten internationalen Fall, der einzige bisher offizielle Fall bei einer Weltmeisterschaft. Und auch der letzte Fall mit Diego Maradona, 94, der glaube ich auch später noch mal auf nationaler Ebene mit verschiedenen Sachen erwischt wurde, wenn ich es so richtig im Kopf habe. Und dann gibt es so verschiedene Generationen, die man immer wieder bricht. Das populärste Beispiel ist, denke ich, Juventus Turin, die Gerichtsverhandlung, die es in Italien gab. Da ging es konkret darum, ob ein gewisser Kreis von Spielern, also das ist die Generation um Zidane und El Piero und so, mit EPO versorgt worden sind. Und dann gab es die Diskussionen rund um Fuentes und Madrid und Barcelona, die dort genannt wurden. Die Proben und Listen mit den Namen, die damals verschwunden sind, ganz plötzlich. Und dann immer wieder deutsche Fälle. Wir sind bei knapp 30 offiziellen Fällen im deutschen Fußball. In meisten Berichten wird da noch eine kleinere Zahl genannt. Wenn man die alle mal zusammenzählt, kommt man schon auf 30. Genau, wenn man das alles zusammen nimmt, gab es eigentlich schon ziemlich regelmäßig Dopingfälle.
Allerdings, ja. Lass noch mal kurz ein bisschen näher auf die einzelnen Fälle eingehen, dass wir da auch quasi alle höhere auf demselben Wissensstand haben. Über die Anabolika-Geschichte beim SC Freiburg und VfB Stuttgart reden wir vielleicht als letztes, weil das jetzt der aktuellste Fall ist. Und da können wir vielleicht auch ein bisschen drüber reden, wie Medien mit solchen Themen generell umgehen. Und jetzt in diesem speziellen Fall, lass noch mal kurz auf Toni Schumacher zurückkommen, den 80ern, das war ja damals tatsächlich, glaube ich, auch so. Diese 54er-Geschichte kam ja auch erst, ich glaube, jetzt nach den 2000ern irgendwann raus. Und die 80er, das war ja damals wirklich so auch der erste große Dopingskandal in Deutschland mit dem Buch Anpfiff. Kannst du uns mal ganz kurz einen Abriss geben, was hat Toni Schumacher in seinem Buch beschrieben?
Ich habe mich lange nicht mit dem Thema beschäftigt. Ich muss tatsächlich jetzt mal nachdenken, was – ich bringe da viele Sachen, glaube ich, durcheinander von Leuten, unterschiedliche Leute, die verschiedene Sachen erzählt haben. Aber so grundsätzlich, also der hat es ziemlich ausgeholt in seinem Buch und hat jetzt nicht nur irgendwie erzählt, ich habe das und das gemacht, sondern das war eine sehr grundsätzliche Debatte, die er ausgelöst hat damals, indem er einfach gesagt hat, die Karten auf den Tisch gelegt hat, was Paul Breitner, der war der Einzige eigentlich, der ihn damals in der Öffentlichkeit so richtig unterstützt hat, wobei ich sagen muss, ich war damals auch erst vier Jahre alt. Ich weiß nicht, wer damals noch wirklich was gesagt hat. Ich kann mir das so nach und dann anlesen. Aber er hat einfach grundsätzlich ausgeholt und wollte mit der Lüge offen, dass Doping im Fußball nicht angewendet wird. Er hat viel darüber berichtet, was alles im Medizinschrank ist, wie Schmerzmittel intensiv angewendet werden. Die bunte Mischung an Medikamenten, was im Zuge der Freiburg-Diskussion noch immer wieder hochkommt, was alles für unterschiedliche Medikamente auch gleichzeitig durch Sportler reinpfeifen. Das waren die verschiedenen Sachen. Es ist spannend zu lesen. Lohnt sich auch das Buch jetzt noch zu stellen, falls man es irgendwo bekommt. Wenn man eh drauf steht, Fußballanekdoten zu lesen und aus dem Inneren was zu erfahren, dann lohnt sich das Buch besonders. Ich habe zuletzt – fällt mir da am Rande ein – dieses Buch gelesen. Wie hieß der Fußballer, der im Buch gestanden hat, dass er Alkohol-Alkoholiker war? Das war, glaube ich, jetzt vor einem Jahr ausgekommen. Ich habe sogar schon den Namen vergessen, der Bremer war es auf jeden Fall. Das war auch so ein Buch, wo die ganze Zeit nette Anekdoten kommen, wo man ein bisschen nostalgisch im Fußball unterwegs ist, was ja viele Fans sind.
Entschuldigung, Uli Borofka natürlich. Ja, Uli Borofka. Aber ein W ist prominent drin.
Uli Borofka, sehr gut, danke.
Mit der Autobiografie volle Pulle.
Genau, volle Pulle. Ich habe die ganze Zeit gehofft, dass da jetzt auch ein bisschen was zu Doping kommt, aber da gibt es noch so Mini-Passagen, wo er nicht wirklich ausspricht oder was los war. Aber wer sich da von solchen Sachen schon begeistern lässt, die noch ziemlich flach in dem Wohl sind, der sollte wirklich auch mal Toni Schumacher lesen, um da ein bisschen seinen Hintergrundsachen zu hören.
Ich habe gerade ein ganz schönes Zitat aus dem Buch von Toni Schumacher vor mir. Beim Training habe ich ein Medikament mit Dopingwirkung ausprobiert. Cap d'Agone heißt das Zeug. Auch in der Fußballwelt gibt es Doping. Natürlich toggeschwiegen, klamm, heimlich, ein Tabu. Später erzählt er dann noch viel von Aufputschmitteln, von Substanzen, die die Angriffslust und Widerstandsfähigkeit erhöhen. Das Ganze in einem Buch, in dem es eigentlich die ganze Zeit nur in diesem Duktus über alle Themen geht. Das ist ja auch das Buch, wo er erzählt, über welche Geldbeträge eigentlich da Poker gespielt wird bei der Nationalmannschaft, nämlich Fünfstellige, dass den ganzen Tag gesoffen und Beischlaf praktiziert wird. Ich erinnere mich noch an das Zitat, manche kamen wie nasse Lappen zum Training, morgens aus dem Bett gekrochen. Das hat damals ganz schön für Aufregung gesorgt. Und auch das, was du schon genannt hast, war ein wesentlicher Punkt. Diese Überversorgung mit Tabletten und mit allen möglichen Schmerzaufputschmitteln. Ich glaube, irgendwo stand, dass er einige der Tabletten dann gar nicht genommen hat und in einen Blumenkübel gekippt hat mit der schönen Formulierung, wo wahrscheinlich Jahre später Schrauben gewachsen sind. So ähnlich habe ich das noch im Kopf. Es liest sich sehr gut, dieses Buch. Ich kann es nur empfehlen.
Vielleicht haben auch Leute gedacht, er hat zu sehr ausgeholt. Deswegen vertraue ich ihm nicht mehr, das ist zu viel, was da drin steht. Wobei ich gerade diese Sachen, jeder hat irgendwie zusammen sich was reingehauen. Ich kenne da auch so ein paar Fälle von Leuten, die mit uns gesprochen haben. Also gerade aus der portugiesischen Liga. Das war irgendwie so Anfang 90er Jahre. Da gibt es einen, mit dem ich mich immer mal wieder unterhalten habe, mit dem ich einfach so auch zusammen kicke. Der hat in der ersten portugiesischen Liga gespielt. Der hat gesagt, es gab regelmäßig Rituale vom Trainer, dass die vom Spielern alle ihre Tabletten bekommen haben und so ein bisschen wie eine Vogelfütterung dann alle ihren Mund aufgemacht haben. Es gab halt mehrere Spieler, die ja keinen Bock drauf hatten, irgendwelche Sachen sich reinzuschmeißen. Dann musstest du halt immer so ein bisschen tun, als ob du das Ding jetzt auch runterschluckst. Das war aber oft so ein Zeug – ich überlege gerade, was die da konkret bekommen hatten – aber es war nicht das effektivste Zeug. Du hast so ein Klassiker-Offputschmittel, wo du 15 Minuten Vollgas geben kannst. Nach 20 Minuten bist du dann aber schon wieder schlapp. Du brennst 15 Minuten wie ein Stier rum. Dann geht es immer mehr Richtung Schnecke. Da gibt es witzige Rituale, die aber von Mannschaft zu Mannschaft und Generation zu Generation sicherlich sehr unterschiedlich sind.
Aber man kann sicher feststellen, auch damals war es schon so, das sehen wir jetzt auch an dem Fall, der jetzt aktuell diskutiert wird, es gehörte einfach zum Usus, sehr, sehr viele Medikamente zu sich zu nehmen. Vielleicht, das ist eine Mutmaßung, dann auch gar nicht mehr so genau nachzufragen, was eigentlich, aber es war jetzt quasi keine Ausnahme, eine Spritze zu bekommen oder eine Tablette zu schlucken, sondern das gehört einfach zum Alltag eines Profis heute wie damals auch dazu.
Ja, also in dem Zusammenhang vielleicht, da ist auch nochmal die Frage, wir haben jetzt schon drüber gesprochen, welche Parameter machen irgendwie Sinn, dass man die mit illegalen Substanzmethoden optimiert, aber auch nochmal grundsätzlich, warum das überhaupt geschieht, dass man den Schritt geht und ich glaube, ein großer Punkt ist, dass du als Sportler immer, also ich glaube, in der Sportsoziologie ist ein Begriff biografische Falle, in der du irgendwie gefangen bist. Du hast dich entschieden, dass du jetzt mit jungen Jahren in der Regel, du möchtest jetzt Fußballer werden, mittlerweile hast du die Möglichkeit, auch in eine duale Ausbildung zu gehen, das war früher noch ein bisschen schwieriger, aber du bist komplett im Fokus und das ist dein Ding. Das heißt, wenn du von dem Weg abkommst, durch eine Verletzung, stärkere Mitspieler, musst du halt überlegen, wie du irgendwie schaffen kannst, den Anschluss zu halten. Und das ist, glaube ich, ein Phänomen, was so viele Spieler dazu bringt, dann tatsächlich auch zu überlegen, ich muss jetzt etwas Verbotenes tun. Das ist sozusagen erstmal die Einzelperspektive, ein Grund, warum Leute zu Doping greifen. Dann hast du deine Vertrauenspersonen, die für dich als Sportler extrem wichtig sind. Also vor allen Dingen der Berater, der irgendwann für dich der wichtigste Mann im Leben wird, sei es eine starke Persönlichkeit oder eine tolle Familie um dich herum, oder andere Leute, die dich so gut beraten können. Oder dass du nicht nur noch auf den einen Typen oder die zwei Typen holst, die du auch bezahlst. Dann hast du den Arzt, den du erstmal finden musst, und dem du dann auch wirklich einfach vertrauen musst, was er mit deinem Körper anstellt. Das ist auch so ein Grund, den ich sehe, warum es immer wieder nur für einzelne Mediziner geht, wo alle Sportler hinrennen. Das ist ein Wohlfalt bei uns in der Gegenwart, das früher Klümper gewesen ist, über die wir später noch sprechen, weil wir über die aktuellen Sachen reden. Und so entwickelt sich – ich kann mir das total gut vorstellen, auch wenn ich nie in dem Bereich unterwegs gewesen bin, aber wenn Leute von damals berichten in irgendwelchen Interviews oder auch uns gegenüber in Gesprächen, wie so eine Abhängigkeit entsteht und wie du auch durch diese Vertrauensperson überhaupt in den dopingen Strudel rein geraten kannst. Auch wenn du überlegst, wie kann ich überhaupt diesen Arzt für mich als Erstes finden, dann frage ich ja Leute in meinem Verein oder andere Leute, denen ich vertraue, die raten mir dann, werden wir einen Arzt nennen, dem sie auch vertrauen. Also es ist ja eine Kettenreaktion, wenn dann alle zum selben Arzt gehen und der vielleicht noch verbotene Sachen macht, dann sind gleich ganz schön viele Spieler betroffen.
Ja und wir haben natürlich die Vereinsärzte, über die es ja dann auch die Möglichkeit gibt, jetzt selbst sollte der Einzelspieler, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, die sich für illegale Mitglieder entschieden haben, gibt es immer noch die Variante, dass es zumindest denkbar ist, dass der Verein als solches vorgibt, hier und da über die Stränge zu schlagen, um es jetzt mal ganz krass zu verharmlosen.
Wobei ich das absolut eine Möglichkeit, wobei ich davon überzeugt bin, dass sich das verändert hat in den Jahren. Also das liegt tatsächlich an den Kontrollen, obwohl ich die immer gern kritisiere. Also früher war es möglich, dass eine ganze Mannschaft gedoppt wurde und dass es auch funktioniert hat, ohne dass es jetzt diese große Explosion gab in der Öffentlichkeit, weil du einfach eigentlich nicht kontrolliert werden konntest. Und auch dieses Doping-Bewusstsein, es gab vielleicht eine Liste, wo drauf stand, dass es verboten ist. Aber solange du nicht ertappt werden kannst, ist es für dich viel leichter gewesen, auch wirklich zu den verbotenen Sachen zu greifen. Mittlerweile ist erstmal der Sport einfach viel globaler geworden. Das heißt, die Spieler wechseln noch viel mehr rund um den Globos. Du hast Spielertypen, wo du überhaupt nicht weißt, was mit denen in zwei Jahren los ist, wo die sonst sind, ob sie dir sauer dein Verein verlassen und im anderen Land vielleicht darüber reden, was in deinem Verein so alles passiert ist. So gibt es so verschiedene Konstellationen, wo ich glaube, dass wenn das von Vereinsseite aus passiert, es eher ein Kreis von Spielern ist, der zusammen – also so ein fest definierter Kreis, der irgendwie die fünf Spieler, die auch über mehrere Jahre in dem Verein unterwegs sind, in der Regel auch immer zum Stamm gehören, dass die sich gegenseitig absprechen können, meinetwegen auch mit Vereinsseite und Verbindung. Ich sage damit nicht, dass der Vereinsarzt immer mal wieder einzelnen Spielern helfen kann, wenn die bestimmte Sachen verlangen und ihm vielleicht noch Tipps gibt. Ich glaube, das wäre hier ganz gut für deinen Körper oder so. Aber so, wie man es im Radsport kennt, dass da ein ganzes Team, die sieben tote-Francs-Fahrer zusammen gedobt sind, das kann ich mir kaum noch vorstellen, dass das so stark existiert. Es gibt allerdings auch Beispiele, wo ich dann Ausnahmen machen würde. Ich überlege gerade, wie ich es formuliere, ohne dass man ganz theoretisch verklagt werden könnte. Aber es gibt ja Konstrukte wie der FC Barcelona, die ein sehr festes Teamgefüge haben, wo sich über sechs, sieben Jahre der Stamm sich kaum verändert. Da gibt es vielleicht drei, vier Positionen, wo das passiert.
Also eine hohe Identifikation auch mit dem Verein vorherrscht. Auch mit den Spieler dort, außer man ist latin.
Ja, genau. Es gibt auch immer Ausnahmen. Also hohe Identifikation mit dem Verein. Auch ein Verein, der dich, wenn du raus bist aus dem Sport oder zum anderen Verein wechselt, dich immer noch um dich kümmert. Du fühlst dich immer noch wertgeschätzt. Und auch ein Verein, der viel Macht hat. Das sind, glaube ich, so Komponenten, wo es für einen Verein möglich ist, auch ein bisschen größere Dinge anzustellen.
Okay, also da kann man einen Wandel vermuten. Und um vielleicht die 80er-Jahre zuzumachen, Toni Schumacher war nicht der Einzige, der damals von Capta-Gon, diesem Aufputschmittel gesprochen hat, sondern später hat dann Peter Neurower auch nochmal gesagt, ich glaube irgendwas in die Richtung, bis zu 50 Prozent haben das konsumiert. Und zwar nicht nur in der zweiten, sondern auch in der ersten Liga. Er hat damals beschrieben, dass man das an den Augen der Gegenspieler immer sehen konnte, wer da drauf ist. Habe ich das so richtig wiedergegeben oder?
Ja, also ich weiß auch nicht mehr 1 zu 1 das Zitat, aber so ungefähr hatte ich das jetzt auch noch im Kopf.
Also es war quasi nicht nur irgendwie Tony Schumacher, der ja auch durchaus auch persönliche Beweggründe gehabt haben könnte, mit manchen Leuten abzurechnen, sondern auch noch andere Quellen, die sich auf die 80er beziehen.
Ja, ja, das hast du absolut recht. Es gab immer wieder Aussagen. Da reichten sogar schon die Suchwetter irgendwie, Doping, Zitate, deutscher Fußball oder sowas. Also auch Christoph Daum hat damals diverse Sachen dazu gesagt. Ich überlege gerade, die Jungs, die jetzt die ganze zitiert werden, Karl-Heinz Förster hat ab und zu mal was rausgehauen, Guido Buchwald habe ich auch noch so grob in Erinnerung, dass er da mal was zugesagt hat. Also da kommt schon ganz gut was zusammen, wenn man das sucht.
Also definitiv jetzt nichts aus der Luft gegriffen ist und bestimmt auch kein Zufall, dass ein Jahr nach Erscheinen des Buchs von Toni Schumacher dann die nationalen Doping-Kontrollen in der Bundesliga eingeführt wurden. Ich selbst kann mich auch nicht dran erinnern, da war ich drei Jahre alt, aber ich vermute da jetzt einfach mal einen Zusammenhang, ohne das jetzt noch mal nacherstestiert zu haben. Gut, das heißt, wir haben in den 80ern definitiv auch zumindest sehr, sehr deutliche Hinweise auf Doping, auch auf nationaler Ebene. Jetzt haben wir in den darauffolgenden Jahren, wenn ich noch mal so deine Beispiele durchgehe, noch ein paar sehr prominente internationale Fälle. Und da steht allen voran 1994 die Ego Maradona. Auf was wurde der damals positiv getestet?
Ich überlege gerade nicht, dass ich Sachen durcheinander bringe, aber eine Sache bin ich mir sicher, das wäre Ephedrin, was ja jetzt noch nicht das superstarke Zeug ist. Das ist ja einfach nur ein bisschen mehr Stimulanz im Prinzip.
Also auch wieder Richtung Aufputschmittel, also quasi, dass man im Moment des Spiels voll auf der Höhe ist, oder wie soll ich das vorstellen?
Genau, genau. Also das sind im Prinzip, also Effidrin ist auch so ein Klassiker von den Proben, die es immer so gab. Ich glaube, das einfachste, um Stimulanz zu erklären, ist eigentlich, dass du es mit einer Koffein-Tablette vergleichst, oder wenn man einen modernen Disco-Drogen nimmt, MDMA, solche Sachen. Du hast halt andere Wahrnehmungsfähigkeit, Pupillen werden ein bisschen vergrößert, bist gepusht für einen gewissen Zeitraum, solche Sachen. Dann gab es bei Maradona, müssten wir nochmal nachschauen, aber ich glaube, das war sogar in derselben Probe, dass das bei ihm zwei Ergebnisse war und das zweite war THC. Nicht das Mittel, da werden immer wieder Sportler mit entdeckt, wo man jetzt denkt, er hat sich da zwar besonders leistungsfreundlich, aber das steht immer auch auf der Liste. Bei Maradona gibt es auch diverse Spekulationen, warum ausgerechnet Diego Maradona jetzt mal bestürzt von der FIFA und nicht irgendwelche anderen Sportler. Es gibt wilde Vermutungen, Mutmaßungen, es ist sehr unterhaltsam, sich da ein bisschen anzulesen, gerade wenn man bei den Argentinern schaut, was wir so zu veröffentlicht haben. Da gab es letztes Jahr auch, ich glaube sogar ein Buch zu, wo es genau um diese Weltmeisterschaft ging und die Theorie, warum Maradona damit seine Karriere beendet werden sollte. Und das ging halt so ein bisschen in die Richtung, Maradona hat eh angefangen, irgendwie Mist zu bauen und angefangen über Sachen zu quatschen. Und eigentlich wurden an dem Tag auch noch andere Spieler getestet, positiv getestet, und am Ende haben sie ihn rausgepickt, ein bisschen zu so Sachen, ihm wurde irgendwas reingemixt und so. Finde ich aber tatsächlich interessant. Also ich kann das natürlich nicht beantworten, ich lese da ja auch nur mit. Aber warum ausgerechnet Maradona 94? Die Leute, die damals ein bisschen älter waren, die können da vielleicht sogar noch mehr zu sagen, weil sie damals um die Berichterstattung verfolgt haben. Ich weiß nicht, ob damals noch ein bisschen mehr bekannt wurde.
Meinst du das Buch Der letzte Maradona von Andres Burgow und Alejandro Valle?
Ja, das waren auf jeden Fall zwei Autoren. Und ist das vom letzten Jahr zu füllig?
Ich glaube, ja. Ja, das ist vom letzten Jahr. Das wird es sein. Von dem hatte ich auch schon vorher gehört. Und hier den Link noch offen. Ein Tatsachenkrimi, schreibt die Süddeutsche. Aber genau, da wurde auch viel drüber berichtet, wie auch die ganze Dopingkontrolle zustande kam, zu welchem Zeitpunkt im Turnier. Sehr interessant.
Und dann gab es im selben Jahr übrigens auch den ersten Dopingfall im deutschen Fußball. Den ersten offiziellen. Also ich glaube, es gab noch vorher einen anderen, aber kann ich gerade noch nicht sagen, weil wir das gerade mal angucken wollten, aber vielleicht bald auf Fußballdoping.de mehr. Aber ich glaube, der DFB führt immer, und das sind auch so die Listen, die im Netz manchmal kursieren, Rodan Wohlfahrt als ersten Fall-off. Wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, das finden wir auch mit ein paar Klicks raus. Das finde ich auch so, der Fun-Fact dabei wurde damals bei einem Heilenturnier erwischt. 1994 war das auch. Der hat auch einen kleinen Sperre bekommen, zwei Monate, soweit ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe. Irgendeine sehr lange Substanz. Ihr werdet merken, wo alle die zuhören, bei den Sachen, wo es dann sehr biologisch wird, da verwechsel ich über vieles. Falls ihr Sachen danach seht, da freue ich mich über die Kommentare.
Wenn ich dir kurz helfen darf, Quelle ist da Fußballdoping.de. Das Aufputschmittel Norefetrin. Und er hat gesagt, daran konnte ich mich auch noch erinnern, er habe einen Appetitzügler zu sich genommen, Ricatol N heißt das. Das war quasi der Befund und die dazugehörige Erklärung war der Appetitzügler.
Ja, Fußballdoping.de. Ich versuche die ganze Zeit nicht auf der Tastatur herumzutippen, wenn dann ganz heimlich, an das Fenster zu wechseln, damit ich meinen Mikrofon nicht so sehr berühre. Aber bei dir höre ich überhaupt nichts, Max, wenn du immer so Sachen dazu droppen kannst. Das ist eine sehr gute Ergänzung.
Ich habe hier wahnsinnig viele Links offen. Die größte Herausforderung ist nur, den richtigen Tab zu finden. Aber gut, der erste deutsche Fall. Dann haben wir als nächsten großen internationalen Fall die Champions-League-Mannschaft von Juventus Turin, die 1996 auch Champions-League-Sieger geworden ist, mit Spielern wie Del Piero und Zidane. Wo spielt das Mittel EPO eine Rolle? Kannst du uns dazu kurz etwas sagen?
Ja, das ist ein komplexer Fall. Der ist mit den Jahren vom Prozess gekommen in Italien. Da waren damals schon andere Wege möglich als in Deutschland, wenn es um das Thema Doping ging. Mittlerweile ist es in Scamta noch viel verschärft, aber es gibt auch ein richtiges staatliches Anti-Doping-Gesetz. Dadurch sind noch mal ganz andere Rechtswege möglich. Es gab Untersuchungen, die sich besonders auf die medizinische Betreuung von Juvenz-Turin damals bezogen. Da ging es viel darum, ob es eine Weitergabe gab, um so eine Art Handel mit verbotenen Substanzen. Da ging es vor allen Dingen um EPO. Wir haben auf unserer Seite einen User, der Italienisch spricht. Die Gerichtsunterlagen stehen übrigens fast alle online von damals zum Prozess. Die findet man ganz schnell. Die sind auch bei uns irgendwo verlinkt, mit denen wir immer hin und her diskutieren. Er sagt, am Ende hätte das Gericht aber gesagt, dass man jetzt nicht mehr sagen kann, dass die Spieler damals EPO bekommen haben. So geht das immer ein bisschen hin und her. Ich habe die Primärquellen immer noch nicht übersetzt bekommen vor Gericht damals. Wenn man jetzt so die normale Berichterstattung verfolgt, dann steht da immer eindeutig, die ganze Juwelmannschaft war mit EPO gedobt. Ich bin mir auch zu 99 Prozent sicher, dass man das sagen kann. Aber so Gerichtsverhandlungen machen ja vieles möglich, dass man plötzlich auf seine Formulierung achten muss. Das sage ich jetzt nicht, weil ich irgendwie Angst habe, dass ich hier die Sachen nicht richtig ausgesprechen habe. Ich wollte nur einen Einblick geben in die Diskussionen. Wir haben deswegen, als wir bei Correktiv angefangen haben, uns auch unsere italienischen Kollegen in Verbindung gesetzt. Wir haben da einen Kooperationspartner des Unternehmen, das nennt sich IRP, also zwei bis vier Journalisten, die von Italien aus auch so investigative Arbeit machen. Die haben sich auch ein bisschen mit dopingem Fußball beschäftigt. Die haben jetzt gerade die Unterlagen noch mal da liegen. Wir sind jetzt im Austausch, ob wir einmal so einen finalen Text – das würden wir so richtig gut tun – zu dem Thema veröffentlichen könnten, wo wir nochmal ganz klar aufschreiben. Das steht übrigens in Gerichtsdokumenten. Jetzt brauchen wir nicht alle voneinander abschreiben, was der Letzte irgendwie geschrieben hat und was man in anderen Texten findet, sondern das sind jetzt die Fakten. Und so können wir das auch formulieren, ohne dass jetzt irgendwer nochmal sagen kann, ne, weil wurden doch alle freigesprochen oder so. Ja, aber viel Spannender, jetzt habe ich viel drumherum geredet, ist halt, um welches Spieler es so ging, welche Generation, ne. Und das ist ja schon eine spannende Generation von Spielern. Also das ist dann wirklich Zidane, De Piero und die Leute, die man dann später noch rund um, bis hin so als Dortmund Champions League-Sieger wurde gegen Juve da miterlebt hat. Und da ging es tatsächlich um die Frage um dieses Mannschaftskonstrukt. Also wurde es zentral von Mannschaftsseite aus gesteuert und auch viel um die Frage, wie groß war der Spielerkreis, der drin war. Und es ging so ein bisschen auch um die Theorie, waren das dann so die sechs bis acht Schlüsselspieler, die da fest mit drin waren im System und auf jeden Fall von Vereinsseite gesteuert.
Ja genau, die Führungskräfte mussten sich damals auch vor Gericht verantworten. Kannst du uns noch kurz was zu dem Wirkstoff sagen? Was macht EPO? Wie setzt man es ein? Warum ist es verboten?
Genau, also EPO ist der Klassiker für Ausdauerfähigkeiten. Es verbessert einfach die Sauerstoffzufuhr für den Körper. Dadurch kann deine Lunge ein bisschen mehr aushalten und du kannst mehr laufen. So ganz grob gesagt.
Also wenn die Sauerstoffzufuhr verbessert wird, dann ist das ja quasi der Effekt, den ich auch bei einem Höhentraining habe, oder? Das hängt, glaube ich, mit den roten Blutköpfe zusammen.
Ja genau, exakt.
Das heißt, die hätten das quasi auch einfach mit Höhenzelten machen können, so wie man es heute ja zum Teil im Sport macht, oder?
Ja, also aus dem Radsport weiß man, dass das auch gerne miteinander kombiniert wird. Und es gab auch so einen Ablöseprozess. Es wurde ja bei langen Jahren überhaupt nicht möglich, Sportler auf Epo positiv testen zu können. Deswegen gab es einen extrem langen Zeitraum, wo du frei losgehen konntest mit Epo. Dass dann überhaupt was rauskommt, ist nachher zu dem Zeitpunkt, dass Leute mit Epo gedobt waren, ist eigentlich schon eine Sensation gerade im Fußball. Und irgendwann gab es dann die Proben. Dann war es aber ganz nur für Einzeln nachweisbar. Ich glaube, jetzt überlege ich, was die Reihenfolge war. Erst Blut oder erst Urin und dann auf jeden Fall danach das andere, nochmal die verbesserte Methode. Ich glaube, erst war es nur im Blut nachweisbar, später auch über die Urinprobe. Zu der Frage, ob in der Höhen-Training-Lager genau das selbe Effekt passieren kann. Deswegen sind meistens von Radsportlern, die gerne Ende der Saison, also für die zwischen November und Januar, ins Höhen-Training-Lager gefahren sind, um genau diesen Effekt zu erzeugen. Die roten Blutkörperchen, die Produktion soll sozusagen angeregt werden. Das ist das perfekte Blut für einen Sportler. Deswegen, als EPO abgelöst wurde, war die neue, populäre Methode, sich genau dieses perfekte Blut abzupumpen, beiseite zu legen, schön zu kühlen und dann im richtigen Moment, ein paar Monate später, zum Wettkampf, paar Tage vor dem Wettkampf, gerne an den Ruhetagen, während der Tour de France zum Beispiel, wieder zurückzuführen. Das ist genau der EPO-Effekt. Und das kann man natürlich auch miteinander mixen. Also du kannst in der Zeit, wo du ein perfektes Blut erzeugen willst, dein Blut auch nochmal zusätzlich punchen, indem du dann nochmal mit EPO was drauflegst, noch besseres Blut produzierst, oder die Anregung der Rotblut-Körbchen noch ein bisschen stärkerst, und dann hast du noch schöneres Blut, was du später wieder zurückführen kannst. Alles ist möglich.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt einfach mal ganz stark verkürze, dann können wir an die Jahrzehnte, die wir besprochen haben, so Etiketten dran kleben. Also im Prinzip haben wir von den 50ern an Aufputschmittel nachgewiesen bei der 54er-Mannschaft. Wir haben in den 70ern dann mit Anabolika ein Medikament, was die Muskelbildung und Ausdauerkraft betrifft. Ich denke, da können wir gleich nochmal dazu sprechen. 80er-Jahre wieder viele Aussagen bezüglich Aufputschmitteln und jetzt dann in den 90ern richtig den aufgeputschten Maradonna. Und aber mit EPO jetzt auch ein richtiges, also eindeutig auf Ausdauer ausgelegt und ja auch hocheffektiv von der Wirkung her. Wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe.
Man muss dazu auch sagen, bevor ich das später vergisse, EPO ist natürlich auch heute noch möglichst nicht damit zu durpen. Das hängt komplett davon ab, auf was man auch die Proben untersucht. Also nur weil du irgendwie Urin und zum Teil Blut nimmst, heißt das ja nicht, dass dann irgendwie die Substanz auch gefunden wird. Du musst für jede Probe immer neu überlegen, auf was teste ich jetzt eigentlich mal eine Probe, wie viel Geld kann ich investieren, um verschiedene Sachen zu testen und so. Und da EPO ist schon ein bisschen ein aufwendigeres Analyseverfahren. Man findet da bei der NADA so ein paar Angaben und bei der VADA in den Jahresberichten, auf was immer so alles getestet wird. Es ist nicht alles komplett transparent, aber kann man auf Nachfragen relativ schnell erfahren. Das ist von Land zu Land auch ziemlich unterschiedlich, so die Möglichkeit. Also es heißt, ich habe die Zahlen leider nicht mehr im Kopf, wie so der Prozentsatz war von Epotest, aber der war erschreckend niedrecht. Also weit habe ich das noch in Erinnerung damals in der Bundesliga.
Okay, das heißt, Dopingkontrolle ist nicht gleich Dopingkontrolle. Wir reden später nochmal darüber, wie das eigentlich im Detail abläuft. Wie muss ich mir das dann vorstellen? Ist der Dopingbereich, der entwickelt sich doch mutmaßlich auch weiter, ist das dann so eine Art Wettrüsten zwischen denjenigen, die neue Dopingsubstanzen herstellen oder neue Aspekte davon irgendwie hervorheben und dann den Labors, die die Tests dafür entwickeln müssen? Ist das so korrekt dargestellt?
Ja, also ich glaube, es gibt zwei entscheidende Faktoren. Das eine ist genau das. Ich möchte dem Labor und den Personen, die mich testen, einen Schritt voraus sein. Das ist nicht das Allerschwierigste, weil das kennt man aus einigen Sportarten, von dem Doping vergangen hat. Wenn du ein bisschen die Möglichkeit hast, einem modernen Doping mit Sachen ranzukommen und auch dafür ein bisschen Geld übrig hast, bist du eigentlich immer einen Schritt voraus. Es wird definitiv mit dem Pharmabereich sehr zusammengearbeitet. Es gibt viele Pharmafirmen, die das gerne nutzen, die die Möglichkeit, Sportler zu haben, an denen sie auch viel die Wirksamkeit testen können. So gibt es sehr viele kreative Wege, da einen Schritt voraus zu zeigen. Der zweite Druckpunkt ist aber auch der direkte Vergleich mit den Konkurrenten. Es gibt auch viele Beispiele. Ich bringe noch mal den Radsport, weil ich mich da mehr auskenne, aber das war das berühmte Retristen, was gerade damals zwischen dem Armstrong-Team und dem Telekom-Team gab. Da ging es wirklich ziemlich wenig darum, immer nur punktuell, wenn mal ein neues Analyseverfahren eingegangen wurde, dass mal umgeswitcht werden musste, deswegen auf eine neue Methode. Aber der eigentliche Antrieb war immer, was macht der Gegner und wie kann ich noch mehr und wirksamer dopen.
Der medikamentös eingeführte Doppel-Diffusor. Eine Formel-1-Analogie zu ziehen. Gut, lass uns noch kurz, jetzt wo wir schon in den 90er sind, können wir jetzt auch noch schnell über die 2000er reden. Gab es danach noch wesentliche Dopingfälle, die wichtig sind zu kennen in dem Bereich Fußball?
Ja, es gab diese eine prominente Phase, die wir vorhin schon angesprochen haben, rund um die ganze Fuentes-Geschichte.
Kannst du uns dann noch kurz den Hintergrund geben, wer es mit Fuentes gemeint ist?
Fuentes war der Mediziner aus Spanien, der 2006 die Bombe geplatzt ist, auch wieder über den Radsport, in dem er als prominenter Doping-Doktor in Tarn wurde, wo, wenn man jetzt so die Tour de France sieht und das Pendanton, vielleicht die Hälfte der Fahrer, die da mitgefahren sind, mit ihm zusammengearbeitet haben.
Also eine irre Masse. Wie viele sind in so einem Pendanton?
Ja, gut 200 Fahrer. Das ist dann schon mal eine ordentliche Masse. Dazu aber auch die anderen Sportdaten. Mit der Zeit, wo das alles aufgerollt ist aus dem Radsport, gab es dann relativ schnell eine Liste, wo noch kodiert drauf stand, wer so alles zu einem Kundenkreis gehörte. Das ist so gelaufen, dass die Guardia Civil, also die spanische Polizeibehörde, die damals die ganze Untersuchung gemacht hat, die haben in den Räumen von Fuentes und seinen Praxen und seinen Partnern viele Blutbeutel gefunden, die beschriftet waren mit unterschiedlichen Zeichen. Sie haben noch Notizbücher von Fuentes und Kollegen gefunden. Und da auch die Codes gefunden. Daraus ist so eine Liste entstanden, die irgendwann im Netz stand. Und bei Wikipedia findet man da mittlerweile auch relativ gut aufgedoset, wer alles draufstand. Und in der Zeit, wo dann nach und nach entschlüsselt, der Code steht für den, da war immer so der Running Gag, dass Fuentes gerne irgendwelche Hunde-Namen von den Leuten verwendet hat. Von Jürg Jakši stand auf jeden Fall der Name von seinem Hund drauf und so und so. Und so konnte man das dann ganz gut nach und nach übersetzen. Und neben dem Radesport gab es dann mehr aus der Leichtathletik und so. Aber aus dem Fußball wurde keiner genannt. Und das ist aus meiner Sicht überhaupt keine Verschwörungstheorie, dass tatsächlich Fußballer auch zu Ends gegangen sind. Da gibt es verschiedene Anhaltspunkte für. Also es gab andere Sportler, die davon gesprochen haben, dass ihnen auch Fußballer dort begegnet sind. Man muss sich vorstellen, dass die Sportler tatsächlich Termine mit dem ausgemacht haben, wie man halt zum Arzt geht, gesagt haben, da die Stunde ist sozusagen für dich reserviert, da kriegst du dein Blut abgepumpt oder Neues zugeführt oder sowas. Abgepumpt war es in der Regel, weil zuführen ist dann ein Wettkampf. Und da kann es gut passieren, dass du halt reinläufst in die Praxis oder am Wartezimmer Platz nehmen musst und dann triffst du irgendwelche anderen Sportler. Also da gab es Aussagen.
Und das ja bei einem, wenn ich richtig informiert bin, Gynäkologe eigentlich.
Ja, genau.
War das auch offiziell seine Praxisbezeichnung? Ich stelle mir das witzig vor.
Er hatte ja so zwei, drei Sitze. Und er hat auch mit dem Blutzentrum zum Beispiel in Barcelona sogar zusammengearbeitet. Also ich kann nicht glauben, bei seiner Praxis stand das sogar so dran. Ich bin mir ganz sicher, aber es war schon klar, dass er ein bisschen mehr dahinter steckte. Schon ein bisschen grotesk einfach.
Und dann gehen da 200 Sportler aus und ein.
Ja, genau richtig. Und dann gab es, glaube ich, wurde es erst populär, sozusagen Aussagen von Foe Inter Saves gegenüber einem Kollegen aus Frankreich, Stephane Mandard. Und da ging es halt darum, dass er ihm eine Liste gezeigt hat von Spielern, die auch bei ihm in Behandlung waren, wo Spieler von Barcelona und Madrid drauf gestanden haben sollen. Da hat dann seine Zeitung auch darüber berichtet, wurde aber heftig verklagt. Und er hatte auch nicht mehr die – er konnte, soweit ich das richtige Erinnerung habe, nur die Dokumente einsehen. hat er sie dann wieder mitgenommen und dadurch hatte er auch für Gericht nicht mehr den Beleg gehabt, auch wenn er für ihn in dem Moment existent war, weil er reinschauen konnte. Aber dadurch hat er verloren. Das war ein ziemlich teures Ding, was er damals, was seine Zeitung bezahlen musste.
Warum hat ihm V.a. das gezeigt?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage, zumal er später immer nur noch Sätze gesagt hat, wie wenn ich da jetzt drüber rede, dann riskiere ich mein Leben. In der Richtung gibt es so ein paar Aussagen. Das hat Fuentes gesagt. Und Fuentes ist, das kam so gerade bei den Gerichtsverhandlungen raus, die vor zwei Jahren waren. Ich glaube, ich habe das in einem Blog damals begleitet. Das ist schon zwei oder drei Jahre her. Zwei Jahre, glaube ich, hochgekommen sind. Er ist schon ein Typ, der auch gerne einfach mal einen auf dicken Macker macht. Und sich da gerne positioniert. Der ist auch stolz darauf gewesen, dass einfach alt die ganze Sportelite zu ihm gekommen ist. Und er sozusagen der Guru für die war. Und dadurch ist er auch mal immer wieder ans Paar angekommen, hat auch vor Gericht definitiv bestätigt, dass Fußballer da waren. Das war sozusagen zum ersten Mal auch dann vor Gericht festgehalten, der Satz. Aber es ging dann nicht mehr in die Tiefe, welche Sportler genau da waren. Aber da in den anderen Sportarten, die einfach nicht die Kraft hatten, jeweils auch wirklich immer die Spitzenathleten genau zuvorenst gegangen sind, ist der Weg nicht mehr so weit, dass man sich dann auch zusammenrechnen kann, welche Sportmannschaften im Fußball werden dann wohl bei ihm vorbeigeschaut haben. Und gerade die enge Verzweigung zwischen Nationalspielern aus Spanien und gleichzeitig prominentsten Vereinsmannschaften, das ist ja auch ein dichtes Netzwerk gewesen, was man gut gleichzeitig bedienen kann. Also das Thema, das wir vorhin aufgeritten haben, wie hält man irgendwie ein Konstrukt von Leuten zusammen, das passt auch alles schon sehr gut zusammen. Das ist so das große Geheimnis, was sich jeder Journalist wünscht, der da irgendwie an dem Thema dran ist, dass man das nochmal wirklich aufdröseln kann. Und irgendwie, es gab in der Geschichte, dass dann genau die Blutbeute verschwunden sind. Das ist nicht sogar nur eine Geschichte. Es sind tatsächlich mehrere Blutbeute verloren gegangen. Das kam vor Gericht bei den Schandungen auch raus. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das nochmal lösen kann. Vielleicht, wenn es noch ein bisschen älter wird und seine Biografie aufschreibt. Ich bin da sehr gespannt.
Und was ist der Grund, dass dem nicht nochmal näher nachgegangen wurde? Ich hätte jetzt gesagt, wenn vor Gericht mir ein dystopisch überführter Arzt sagt, ich hatte auch Fußballer, dann gehe ich als Staatsanwalt hin und versuche, alles herauszufinden. Super Nachfrage.
Genau in dem Moment, wo er das ausgesprochen hat, hat die Richterin gesagt, wir wollen uns jetzt nicht über einzelne Sportarten unterhalten, wir wollen doch grundsätzlich das System verstehen. Also er hatte auch gesagt, auch Tennis und Fußball, ich glaube, Tennis war ja eine andere Sportart. Das war gleich am ersten Tag. Ich hatte auch die komplette Medienaufmerksamkeit gehabt in dem Prozess. Da gab es mehrere Verhandlungstage. Und dann hat die Richterin genauso reagiert, aber darüber wollen wir jetzt gar nicht reden. Wir machen uns hier mit dem Prozess weiter. Also seitdem ist der Verdacht irgendwie nahe. Die Justiz steckt dann auch noch drin. Also wie mächtig ist der Fußball? Achso, noch eine Sache, die ich komplett vergessen habe, was auch belegt ist durch Dogoskumenten, ist dann der nächste Verein San Sebastian, der mit drinsteckt. Darüber kann man auch tatsächlich sprechen, weil das der einzige Fußballverein in den Akten aufgetaucht ist. Da gab es Bestellungen, die tatsächlich auch über einen deutschen Arzt abgelaufen sind, Markus Scheuner. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange das jetzt her ist, dass das mal durch die Medien ging, aber das ist immer so der Verdachtsmoment, dass man über Scheuner die Bestellungen – vorhin hat sich in den Ländern Leute gesucht, mit denen er zusammenarbeiten kann, Vertrauensärzte für ihn, die ihm auch mal dort das Blut abnehmen können oder was zurückführen oder Medikamente hinbringen können. Und da lief eine Bestellung über Markus Scheuner, der so Sachen – ich glaube auch Akto-Vegin, dieses Kälberblutmittel, das Müller-Wolff hat, immer gern spritzt und andere Sachen, das Sebastian geliefert hat. Und die ganzen Namen tauchen dann auch in den Ermittlungsakten auf.
Das heißt, Bestellung bedeutet in dem Fall jetzt, sie haben nicht Blut bestellt, weil da vielleicht erst mal Blut liefern müssen, sondern da geht es dann um Medikamenten-Doping?
Genau, in dem Fall gab es, hatte der deutsche Apothekenmarkt, glaube ich, einfach ein paar andere Medikamente im Angebot, die dann darüber bestellt wurden. Genau, und bestens über Standard damals Schabuja Lontso, genau in der Zeit gespielt, der bevor er dann zur EIMA tritt und mittlerweile auch Bayern und China gewechselt ist.
Okay, das heißt, wir haben quasi bei Fuentes ein Fragezeichen, das eigentlich kein wirkliches Fragezeichen ist, wenn man eben nicht Jurist ist. Es besteht eine hohe Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass er nicht nur mit allen anderen Sportarten zusammengearbeitet hat, sondern auch mit Fußballern. Bei San Sebastian haben wir es definitiv auch vor Gericht bestätigt. Spekulationen gibt es in die Richtung Barcelona und Madrid, habe ich das so richtig zusammengefasst.
Genau, und wer das für dich möchte, dem verweise ich jetzt mal komplett Eigenwerbung auf meinen eigenen Blog. Ich habe damals eine Dokumentation von Gerichtsprozessen gemacht. Bei Fußballdoping haben wir auch noch was durchgeschrieben, da könnte das noch vertiefen. Ich habe vielleicht auch nicht mehr alles um den Kopf.
Das packen wir auch alles in die Show und vielleicht noch kurz zum Hintergrund wissen. Real Madrid ist Champions League-Sieger geworden in der 98, 2000, 2002 und 2006 kam dann Fuentes. Wer weiß, wie weit das zurückgehen könnte. Barcelona ist auch Champions League-Sieger geworden, als dann auch die ganze Fuentes-Bombe geplatzt ist, wie du es formuliert hast. Gut, das heißt, das ist dieser prominente Fall, der auch groß durch die Medien ging. Gibt es noch einen anderen, größeren Fall in der jüngeren Vergangenheit, den man wissen sollte?
Ja, man könnte jetzt nochmal, es gibt ja immer wieder, 2005 war der Conference Cup bei uns in Deutschland, oder? 2005, genau, da gab es ja diese Geschichte mit den Mexikanern, die abgereist sind, die vier, waren das vier Spieler oder so, bei denen auch, ich glaube, die haben am Anfang noch mitgespielt, dann gab es tatsächlich eine positive Probe beim Turnier. Ich habe jetzt tatsächlich noch etwas geöffnet, wo ich mir mal alle Fälle irgendwie abgespeichert habe, vielleicht kriege ich das ja mal mit ganz wenigen Klicks jetzt auch raus.
Dann kann ich vielleicht noch kurz einstreuen. Meine Erinnerung an den Confed Cup 2005 ist ja immer noch, ich glaube, das war es nicht sogar, das Finale zwischen Brasilien und noch jemanden in der Commerzbank-Arene, das hat so sehr geregnet, dass man das Dach ausfahren musste zum ersten Mal, und dann hat man leider festgestellt, ach, ist nicht dicht, und direkt neben der Eckfahne ging ein Sturzbach runter, da musste Ronaldinho, glaube ich, noch in eine Ecke treten. Und das werde ich nicht vergessen, wie es damals aussah, und vor allem, wie sich die, wie sich ganz Deutschland vor Kram gebeugt hat, ausgerechnet die Weltmeister im Organisieren, kriegen sowas nicht gebacken. Das fand ich, habe ich mich vor allem sehr gerne daran zurückerinnert, als vor der WM jetzt in Brasilien immer wieder gesagt wurde, oh, ob die überhaupt fertig werden mit ihren Stadien, da dachte ich mir so, ey Leute, wir haben unser Dach auch nicht hingekriegt, zumindest nicht zum Konfett Cup.
Das ist eine super Brücke gewesen, finde ich gut. Ich habe damals auch ein Konfett Cup-Spiel im Hannover gesehen. Ich habe derweil die Fälle gefunden, es waren drei Fälle, drei Mexikaner, zwei davon auf Nandrolon, das ist ein Mittel, das immer wieder auftaucht, das ist ein Mittel, das besonders gerne nach Verletzung verwendet wird, um den Muskelaufbau wieder zu besteunigen, also ein sogenanntes Anabolissteroid. Das ist ein Doping-Klassiker, gerade im Fußball, neben den kleinen Sachen wie THC und was immer wieder kommt, Nandrolon ist ganz beliebt, zieht sich mal wieder durch alle Fälle. Ich weiß nicht, ob das auf FIFA-Ebene war, aber beim größeren Turnier waren das vielleicht die letzten populären Fälle. Sonst gab es auch mal Qualifikationsspieler aus allen kleinen Ländern, wo Leute aufgetaucht sind. Eine Sache habe ich natürlich komplett vergessen, die Nordkoreanerinnen 2011, wo die halbe Mannschaft erwischt wurde, auch mit irgendwelchen Anabolikern, die dann alle zwei Jahre gesperrt wurden. Man weiß nicht mehr, was mit den Mädels passiert ist. Das waren acht Spieler, die damals erwischt wurden. 2011 ist nicht so lang. Rund um Ajax und Amsterdam gibt es auch noch diverse Theorien. Ich kann hier aber gar nicht so tief einsteigen, weiß nicht mehr so genau. Aber es gibt auch immer wieder… Ebi Smolarek ist auch jemand, der mit Dortmund damals getestet wurde, 2002. Ja, ich könnte jetzt noch einige Namen zwischendurch nennen. Vielleicht noch von deutschen Namen. Es ist ja auch immer interessant, wer sich damit beschäftigt hat. Ibrahim Tanko hatten wir den schon genannt. Er hat glaube ich auch noch gekifft. Marco Rehmer auf jeden Fall. Das war – was hatte Rehmer denn nochmal? Falls du das gegoogelt bekommst, nebenbei. Auf jeden Fall waren es ein paar Monate Sperre.
Wir müssen noch kurz nachfügen, dass Ebi Smolarik damals vor einem Spiel gegen Dortmund getestet wurde. Er hat bei Fairnought gespielt. Nicht, dass sonst die Dortmund-Fans aufs Dach steigen. Ich glaube, das ist auch um Cannabis gehen. Da bin ich mir jetzt aber nicht ganz sicher.
Ja, man findet dabei, dass es auch so jemanden gibt, der auf jeden Fall mindestens einen Fall hatte, der – wie heißt der? Rumäne.
Mensch, naja. Ich habe auch noch einen wunderschönen Begriff für dich. Du hast gefragt, was Marco Rehmer hatte. Er hat ein Medikament genommen, angeblich von seinem HNO-Arzt verschrieben, das das Glucocortico-Steroid-Beta-Metason enthielt. Das hätte man aber auch wirklich auswendig.
Ja, das hätte man auswendig wissen müssen. Ja, macht Spaß. Ich kann an der Stelle nur ankünden, wie – ich hatte ja vorhin schon gesagt, ich fand das auch spannend, mal zu gucken, was da im deutschen Fußball genau unterwegs war. Das ist auch so ein Klassiker, dass man das gerne voneinander kopiert, die Dopingfälle im deutschen Fußball. Wir wollen dazu auch noch mal etwas ausführlicher machen. Wir hatten das ganz am Anfang, als unsere Seite live ging, schon mal gemacht. Mittlerweile ist ja noch mal ein bisschen was passiert. Wir wollen uns die einzelnen Fälle auch noch mal stärker anschauen, wie eigentlich so die Geschichte hinter den Fällen war. Weil du hast jetzt gerade gesagt, dass die Ausrede von Marco Rema, das muss ja tatsächlich auch keine Ausrede gewesen sein. Das kann man auch gar nicht pauschal sagen. Ich kann mir das auch ganz gut vorstellen. Tatsächlich ist es passiert, dass der Spieler in dem Moment nicht wusste, was er da bekommen hat. Ich finde es schwierig, wenn man immer hört, Nahrungsergänzungsmittel aus Versehen am Essen eingenommen oder so. Da wäre ich immer gleich hell durch. Was ich mir aber schon vorstellen kann, ist, was immer mal wieder passieren kann, dass einem der Mannschaftsarzt tatsächlich was gegeben hat. Und du dich einfach nicht vernünftig informiert hast, was in dem Mannschaftsarzt Bescheid wüsste, was in dem Moment passiert. So solche Konzentrationen oder über den Hausarzt, Sachen, den du eh, was ich vorhin schon gesagt habe, mit dem, du hast einen Guru, wo du immerhin gehst und irgendwann fragst du auch nicht mehr nach, was er dir da jetzt genau spritzt. Hauptsache, es hilft. Das kann schon sein, kann auch sein, dass es bei Riemann damals so gewesen ist.
Aber ich denke, man kann jetzt am Ende dieses Jahr doch sehr langen Abschnittes sagen. Also die Aussage, Doping im Fußball gab es nicht, ist definitiv falsch. Es gab viele Fälle. Man kann mutmaßen, dass es eventuell noch mehr gibt, die nicht aufgedeckt sind. Das muss jeder für sich selbst entscheiden. Aber es gibt definitiv nachgewiesenes Doping im Fußball, und zwar über alle Jahrzehnte hinweg. Und mit eigentlich allem, was auch so zur Verfügung stand, von Aufputtschmitteln bis hin jetzt dann zur Formel-1-Version EPO, sage ich mal. Das Doping haben wir alles gefunden. Und jetzt haben wir aktuell, das wussten wir, bevor wir diesen Termin für diesen Podcast ausgemacht hatten, noch gar nicht, dass das kommen würde, haben wir eine aktuelle Entwicklung. Das heißt, es wurde etwas aufgedeckt, was wieder um den Zeitraum der 70er und 80er berief. Magst du uns kurz erzählen, um was es da geht? Genau.
Also es gibt in Freiburg, an der Uni Freiburg, gab es ja schon verschiedene Veröffentlichungen zu der Doping-Vergangenheit dieser Uni Freiburg. Das ist eine Sache, die sich schon lange hinzieht. Dadurch wird verschiedene Kommissionen und Personen versucht, das so nach und nach aufzuarbeiten, besonders durch wissenschaftliche Ansätze. Das sind dann genauer diese Sachen. Damals durch das Team Telekom Ratschmutt ist das bekannt geworden, dass es Ärzte gab, die bei Team Telekom – also Schmidt und Heinrich heißen beiden Ärzte – als Mannschaftsärzte angestellt waren, gleichzeitig an der Uni Freiburg. Über die Uni Freiburg wurde dann systematisch ein Doping-Netzwerk aufgebaut, wo selbst Fahrer während der Tour des Rangs nach Freiburg gefahren sind, an einem Ruhetag oder so, um sich dann noch mal Sachen zuführen zu lassen und solche Geschichten. Da ist mittlerweile schon ziemlich weit aufgeklärt, wie das abgelaufen ist. Was nach und nach immer mehr rausgekommen ist, ist, was davor eigentlich schon alles passiert ist. Und die Uni Freiburg hat da wirklich eine ganz, ganz düstere Vergangenheit, die schon in den 80ern und vielleicht sogar früher losging. Und da gab es einen Arzt, Armin Klümper, den vielleicht mehrere Leute kennen. Der ist besonders durch den Fall Birgit Dressel bekannt geworden. Die Leichtathletin, die irgendwann plötzlich tot in ihrem Zimmer lag und in ihrem Zimmer wurden, ich glaube die grobe Zahl war immer so über 100 verschiedene Medikamente gefunden, die sie sich danach und danach umjagen gesammelt hatte. Und die ist dann so im Prinzip durch einen wilden Medikamentencocktail letztendlich zu Tode gekommen. Und weil es halt wurde von Klümpa unter anderem versorgt damals. Und so gibt es sehr viele Aussagen über Klümpa. Der nach und nach wurde das immer mehr aufgearbeitet, was er alles angestellt hat. Das war halt der Guru, wo es wirklich all möglichen Sportarten, die Leute hingereist sind, eng mit der Politik verflechtet. Meier Vorfelder, um mal zum Fußball zu kommen, ist einer, der ihn auch immer wieder gelobt hat. Und damals, also für lange Zeit, ja auch Präsidentin beim VfB Stuttgart war. Und was jetzt schon immer schon bekannt war, ist, dass es irgendwie auch Verbindungen gibt zwischen dem Fußball und Klümpa und Freiburg. Das waren so Sachen wie Sportler, die den Klümpa mitfinanziert haben. Der wurde, muss man dazu wissen, lange über Steuergelder finanziert, über das Bundesinnenministerium, was bei uns ja viele Fördergelder für den Sport und auch für die Sportmedizin gibt und verschiedene Bereiche. Und irgendwann ist es ausgelaufen, da wurde ein Förderverein gegründet, da saßen unsere Leute drin, die Hansi Müller gegen gegründet haben, extra nur, um für Klümpa in Zukunft noch Geld besorgen zu können. Und so gab es halt schon Sachen, die jetzt immer nach und nach immer aufgetaucht sind. Aber es gab noch nicht den konkreten Dopingbezug sozusagen zwischen dem Fußball und Freiburg und Klümpa. Und das ist jetzt zum ersten Mal durch ein Mitglied dieser Untersuchungskommission, die immer noch läuft, den Abschlussbericht jetzt bis zum Ende des Jahres veröffentlichen möchte, zum ganzen Vorfeld sagen veröffentlicht worden. Ich glaube, auf den Prozess gehen wir jetzt nicht so sehr ein, was da mit der Kommission jetzt los ist. Sonst verlieren wir uns da. Aber was jetzt in der Vorabmeldung sozusagen zu den Berichten der Bericht, der aber erst noch wirklich veröffentlicht werden soll, auf 60 Seiten etwa drinstand, ist, dass Stuttgart und Freiburg von der Uni Freiburg Anabolika regelmäßig bestellt haben. Gegen Klümper gab es mal auch in der Staatsanwaltschaft Freiburg ein Ermittlungsverfahren, da ging es, glaube ich, um Steuerbetrug. Und in dem Rahmen haben sie alle möglichen Dokumente angeschaut und dann haben sie auch so eine Liste gefunden, wo einfach Abrechnungen zwischen den Vereinen und Klümper. Und da tauchen immer wieder Anabolika-Bestellungen und alle möglichen anderen Mittel noch auf. Mit allen möglichen anderen meine ich jetzt nicht Lopingmittel, aber Anabolika dreht sich jetzt gerade in der Diskussion. Und das ist ein Zeitraum von Ende der 70er bis Anfang der 80er Jahre. Und es ist ein interessanter Zeitraum, weil in der Zeit Stuttgart extrem erfolgreich auch gespielt hat. In den knapp zehn Jahren, um die es da geht, war Stuttgart Vizemeister mehrmals auf Platz 3 und 4. Die waren da echt gut unterwegs. Und da tauchen auch viele Namen auf, die haben jetzt einfach noch was sagen. Jogi Löw ist ein ganz prominentes Beispiel. Anfang der 80er war Stuttgart und auch noch bei Freiburg. Also gleich die Doppelkonstellation hat dort in dem Verein gespielt. Rainer Artreon kennt man ja auch durch seine Nachwuchsarbeit in der Nationalmannschaft und bei Stuttgart. Und so gibt es mehrere Namen, die man irgendwie kennt. Es gibt allerdings, muss man dazu sagen, in diesen Tabellen, die da aufgetaucht sind, die Abrechnung, jetzt keinen konkreten Bezug zu den Spielern, sondern immer nur die Abrechnung zwischen Verein und Freiburg, also der Uni.
Das heißt, hier sprechen wir von nachweisbarem systematischen Doping durch den Verein.
Ja, also ich würde total gerne diesen Sonderbericht lesen. Das ist schade, dass das jetzt so als quasi so eine Pressemitteilung, bevor irgendwann das Ding veröffentlicht wird, so rausgehauen wurde. Dann könnte man das noch viel besser formulieren. Aber so formulieren, dass die Wissenschaft da ja – und die haben sich Dokumente angeschaut und die sprechen von systematischem Doping von Vereinsseite aus.
Gut, das heißt im Grunde dann, wenn wir jetzt mal wieder zurückgucken, dann der erste nationale Dopingfall ist dann eben nicht mehr Roland Wohlfahrt, sondern ganze Mannschaften in den 80ern, die auch sehr erfolgreich waren. Also ich habe es gerade nochmal aufgerufen, weil man sich das aufgrund der aktuellen Tabellensituation gerade nicht so vorstellen kann. Sorry liebe VfB-Fans, aber wenn man jetzt die Tabellenposition von 1980 angeht, dann war Stuttgart zweiter, dritter, dritter, neunter, dritter und dann Deutscher Meister. Also durchaus sehr erfolgreich. So, jetzt ist das zutage getreten, ja auch gar nicht so freiwillig. Also da ist jemand vorgeprescht in dieser Kommission. Und jetzt kann man eigentlich ganz gut an diesem Beispiel durchspielen, wie Medien mit diesem Thema umgehen. Und wir haben dazu mal zwei Örtönen mitgebracht. Vielleicht hören wir jetzt einfach mal in den ersten Reihen. Und wir hören jetzt einfach mal, was Jürgen Klopp nach dem DFB-Pokalspiel gegen Dynamo Dresden sagt auf die Frage flächendeckendes Doping im Fußball möglich.
Flächendeckendes Doping im Radsport, wissen wir, hat es gegeben, ist möglich. Aber Doping als systematische Verabreichung von Anabolikern im Fußball, das kommt überraschend spät auf einmal daher und als Tageslicht, was Ende der 70er, Anfang der 80er beim SC Freiburg und insbesondere beim VfB Stuttgart passiert sein soll. Als Sie das jetzt gehört haben, für Sie vorstellbar, oder haben Sie gedacht, hey, was ist denn das für eine Nummer?
Na ja, Fußballer sind in dem Bereich wirklich tatsächlich nicht systematisch unterwegs. Ich glaube, in keiner Zeit gewesen, sondern im Fußball ist da viel zu wenig drum gekümmert worden. Aber wenn man sich in Freiburg zu der Zeit damals hat häufiger behandeln lassen, dann glaube ich, dann kann das passiert sein, ohne dass es jemand mitbekommen hat. Ich glaube, die haben da ein bisschen vor sich hingetestet. Die haben über Jahrzehnte einen Riesenruf gehabt, und der ist relativ schnell dann auch komplett kaputt gemacht worden. Und ich bin mir ganz sicher, die Spieler, die damals beim VfB Stuttgart gespielt haben, da war überhaupt keiner dabei, dem man das auch nur im Ansatz zutrauen würde. Ach, um Himmels willen. Es kann sein, dass im Fußball mal irgendwann gedobt wird. Das ist immer von der medizinischen Seite, die irgendwas ausprobieren. Aber dass die Spieler in irgendeiner Form glauben, damit können wir uns ein bisschen weiterhelfen oder so was. So funktioniert das Fußballgeschäft überhaupt nicht. Und dementsprechend auch damals nicht. Wenn die was gekriegt haben, dann haben sie es sicher nicht gewusst.
Jonathan, wenn du diese Aussagen von Jürgen Klopp hörst, erkennst du da bestimmte Muster wieder, mit denen sich jetzige und ehemalige Akteure zu Doping im Fußball äußern?
Ja, ich finde es total interessant, wie Klopter Porsche seine Kollegen freispricht. Er spricht über eine Generation, mit der er sich vielleicht mal darüber unterhalten hat, was damals los war, aber er war auf jeden Fall nicht aktiv drin in dem Kreis und sagt dann so Sätze wie, wenn die was gekriegt haben, also ganz vielleicht, falls sie mal was bekommen, dann haben sie es auf keinen Fall gewusst. Da haben irgendwelche Leute so ein bisschen rum experimentieren, ein bisschen Spaß gehabt. Aber der Fußball, der Heilige, der hat da nichts zu tun. Ich finde, das ist ein sehr typisches Verteidigungsmuster, obwohl er sich ja gar nicht verteidigen muss. Aber wir sind eine Sportart und wir werden in dem Moment angegriffen. Und jetzt kommt die Verteidigung.
Und jetzt haben wir in dem O-Ton auch gehört, wie Reinhold Beckmann von der ARD überhaupt die Frage stellt. Mein Eindruck war, es wird sich schon mal vorab so ein bisschen entschuldigt, dass man jetzt überhaupt über das Thema sprechen muss. Interpretiere ich da zu viel rein oder ist das auch symptomatisch dafür, dass Doping auch einfach nicht gerne thematisiert wird?
Ja, total. Ich finde es im TV-Business eh schwierig. Ich kann das auch verstehen, dass es für die Journalisten in dem Moment schwierig ist, weil sie sich auch so eine Konstruktion geschaffen haben, wo sie nun mal extrem eng mit den Sportlern zusammenarbeiten. Das sind jeder Sport dazu. Das ist im Fußball allein schon durch die Situation, dass du immer die ehemaligen dabei hast, die aber gar nicht so lange ehemalige sind. Du triffst die Leute regelmäßig wieder, sitzt abends oft, hört man ja immer wieder, gerade bei den Kommentatoren, dann noch mit irgendwelchen Spielern zusammen in der Kneipe. Du hast ganz viele Situationen, wo du sehr eng beieinander bist. Und dazu noch die Abhängigkeit. Wenn du Leute angreifst, kannst du dein Produkt verloren gehen. Es kann sein, dass du bestimmte Interviewpartner nicht mehr bekommst. Hört man ja auch immer wieder. Sie sind nicht zufrieden, wie der eine Reporter sich geäußert hat, zu dem kriegt der ganze Sender jetzt erstmal keine Interviews mehr. Oder so solche Geschichten. Bei so einer Drooping-Geschichte ist es natürlich noch ein bisschen direkter. Ich finde es journalistisch natürlich extrem schwach, aber dass er da nicht in der Lage ist, da vernünftige Follow-up-Fragen zu stellen oder seine Frage einfach klar und hart zu formulieren, eine Pause zu lassen. Und jetzt muss Klopp kommen. Ja, das ist einfach dieses Konstrukt im Sport. Die Abhängigkeit ist viel zu nahe.
Weil eben dann die Journalisten letztlich eigentlich gar kein Interesse daran haben, diese Negativgeschichten aufzudecken?
Muss man von Journalist zu Journalist, glaube ich, einzeln sich anschauen, was das für Typen sind, möchte ich gar nicht so pauschal sagen. Aber wenn wir jetzt mal andersherum, wie man aus meiner Sicht es hätte machen müssen, er hat eine ewig lange Einleitung in dem Moment schon verwendet, dann könnte er einfach sagen, das kam jetzt raus, Anabolika, die Kommission sagt, Stuttgart und Freiburg systematisch eine Frage und dann rauben lassen, um ihn zu antworten. Nicht drei, vier Fragen da schon eine Entschuldigung einbauen, die er dann gleich aufgreifen kann. Und wenn er dann so einen Satz sagt, Klopp hat auch so etwas gesagt wie, jetzt habe ich den nicht mehr ganz im Kopf, aber er hat so einen Widerspruch drin gehabt. Na okay, kann ich jetzt nicht mehr drauf eingehen. Da müsste ich mir nochmal genau anschauen. Aber hinzu wäre die Möglichkeit für Beckermann gewesen, danach auch eine Nachfrage zu stellen. Wie kommt es denn dann dazu, dass Anabolika-Mittel auftauchen? Es gibt ja zig Möglichkeiten, darauf einzugehen.
Also den Widerspruch, den ich ja so ein bisschen gesehen habe, ist, dass er auf der einen Seite sagt, dieses Argument, was wir ganz am Anfang schon ein bisschen widerlegt haben, also es bringt ja überhaupt gar nichts. Er kann sich nicht vorstellen, dass die Spieler irgendwie glauben, dass ihnen das weiterhilft. Und direkt danach sagt er relativ bald, aber wenn sie was gekriegt haben, dann haben sie es sicher auch nicht gewusst. Also dann gäbe es ja doch den Grund, wieder was zu geben. Gut, aber wir müssen jetzt auch keine Exegese von Statements von Jürgen Klopp machen. Nur als Beispiel. Was ich noch interessant fand, auch an der ganzen Fragestellung war, dass so fast als Vorwurf formuliert wurde, dass diese Dopingpraxen jetzt erst aufgedeckt werden.
Ja, ja, das ist gerade mal – da finde ich total gut den Punkt. Das ist eine Sache, die man eigentlich von den Sportfunktionären und ehemaligen eher gehört hat. Was soll denn das, warum redet ihr denn da jetzt drüber? Aber wenn man überlegt, das ist doch ein Kernelement des Journalismus in der Recherche, dass man über vergangene Missstände spricht, die nur in der Vergangenheit liegen können, um in Zukunft solche Sachen vermeiden zu können und da irgendwie für eine, ich sag mal, bessere Gesellschaft sorgen zu können. Und das ist nun mal immer in der Vergangenheit. Da gibt es bestimmte Sachen, da muss man lange warten, bis man dann drüber sprechen kann und die Erkenntnisse hat. Und gerade, wenn man sich anschaut, wodurch Dopingfälle bekannt geworden sind, dann sind das halt oft so Sachen, dass Wissenschaftler sich ran trauen und Zeit bekommen und Zugang zu Archiven, zu Staatsanwaltschaften, weißt du was ich alles, um dann auch an Sachen in Quellen zu kommen, die man sonst nicht hatte. Das braucht einfach Zeit. Eine andere Möglichkeit ist, dass es Gerichtsprozesse gibt, die irgendwann dann mal beginnen und irgendwann auch ein Ende finden. Das ist auch eine Zeit, die lange dauert. Neben positiven Proben, aber davon gibt es ja gar nicht so viele. Oder Zugang zu Zeitzeugen, die erst vielleicht Jahrzehnte später Interesse haben, über das zu sprechen, wo sie aus dem Sport komplett draußen sind und nicht immer zum inneren Kreis gehören. Das braucht einfach Zeit. Das finde ich extrem falsch, daraus einen Vorwurf zu kreieren, das ist zu lange her, warum soll man es noch damit beschäftigen?
Und dann hatten wir noch in derselben Berichterstattung wurde auch noch mit Mehmet Scholl über das Thema gesprochen, was dahingehend interessant war, dass er dann noch mal ein bisschen den Blick auf den des Akteurs richtet, also des Profisportlers, und er erzählt, was seine Meinung zu dem Thema ist. Hören wir noch mal kurz rein.
Flächendeckendes Doping im Radsport, in Ausdauersportarten, alles vorstellbar, alles dagewesen im Fußball?
Zunächst mal fehlt mir bei der Diskussion die Frage, was soll es überhaupt bringen im Fußball? Fußball ist so eine komplexe Sportart. Das heißt, nimm mal an, du nimmst was zum Muskelaufbau. Darunter leitet die Koordination, darunter leitet die Schnelligkeit. Nein, nicht die Schnelligkeit, die Koordination. Dann nimmst du was für die Kondition, dann wirst du langsamer. Also im Fußball macht es nicht wirklich Sinn. Ich kann mir vorstellen, so wie Klopo das gesagt hat, man probiert das einfach mal. Man hat einfach die Fußballer so ein bisschen als Versuchskaninchen benutzt. Vielleicht wusste der eine oder andere auch, was er da nimmt, aber nicht welche Wirkungen es auf den Körper hat. Also ich kann aus meiner aktiven Zeit nur sagen, 15 Jahre bei Bayern München, ich hatte jede Menge Dopingkontrollen, wir alle. Und ich halte es damit, wir hatten einen Medizinschrank, da waren Medikamente für Kinder drin. Wir haben überhaupt nichts nehmen dürfen. Die Mittel waren so sanft. Ich erinnere an die Worte von Jens Jeremies, der immer wieder sagte, wenn er gesagt hat, wo gehst du hin, habe ich gesagt, ich gehe zur Dopingkontrolle. Und dann hat er gesagt, du brauchst da nicht hin. Ich habe gefragt, warum nicht? Er hat gesagt, Millionen haben gesehen, dass du nicht gedoppt bist.
Jens Jeremies, der letzte große Fußballphilosoph und passt auch ganz gut zu Dresden, denn hier war es ein fußballerisches Zuhause.
So, wir haben also mehr mit Scholl gehört in seiner typischen Art. Er ist dann nochmal schön mit einem Anekdötchen rausgegangen. Aber lass nochmal kurz darauf eingehen, was er so anspricht als Reaktion auf diese Frage. Zum einen eben das eine Argument, Doping im Fußball bringt es nicht. Das ist einfach falsch.
Genau, das haben wir ja im Prinzip heute hoffentlich auch schon genügend widerlegt. Ich finde bei der Situation total kurios, dass Scholl ja komplett vorbereitet ist auf die Frage. Er hat den Senderablauf vor sich liegen, er wusste genau, jetzt kommt die Frage und ich muss jetzt auch nochmal einen Statement dazu abgeben. Und dann haut er so einen Scheiß raus. Ich finde, das ist gerade im Medienbereich – gut klar, Scholl spricht auch immer ein bisschen freier – aber im Medienbereich bist du so gebrieft und geschult und hast deine Standardarbeit parat. Aber wenn es das Thema Doping zur Sprache kommt, dann scheitern so viele Fußballer daran, eine vernünftige Antwort auszukriegen und vielleicht auch nur drei Sätze lieber zu sagen und dann nicht noch zehn weitere, die komplett irre sind. Das finde ich schon großartig.
Was sagst du zu diesen Verharmlosungen, die er verwendet? Also einmal sagt er die Fußballer als Versuchskaninchen und auf dem anderen nur Medikamente für Kinder.
Ja, gerade das mit dem Medizinschrank ist absurd. Also was sind denn jetzt genau Medikamente für Kinder, die da irgendwie rumliegen? Da gibt es ja bei Bayern dann auch Parallelen, dass man sich an den Fall Breno erinnert, der damals sich geäußert hat, dass bei Bayern immer ein Medizinschrank mit einem möglichen Zeug drin lag. Und da klang es überhaupt nicht mehr verharmlosend, was da freizugänglich war für die Spieler. Wenn man das noch im Hinterkopf hat und da einfach so einen Kinderzirkus draus baut, das ist komplett unglaubwürdig. Und dazu noch der Satz, wir mussten zigmal zu Dopingkontrollen. Wenn man sich die Dopingzahl anguckt in seiner aktiven Zeit, die waren noch deutlich geringer als heute. Und heute schon, klar, als Nationalspieler noch ein bisschen öfter, aber sonst wirst du wirklich nicht so oft kontrolliert. Wenn du dein ganzes Leben zusammenrechnest, deine aktive Karriere, dann ist das vielleicht die persönliche Wahrnehmung. Aber nicht im Verhältnis zu anderen Sportarten.
Das heißt, wir haben jetzt als Reaktion von Verantwortlichen jetzt in diesem einen Fall eine ganze Palette an Argumentationsmustern, die immer wiederkehren. Ich kann noch ergänzende Robin Dutt, der Sportdirektor vom VfB, hat auch noch in der ARD gesagt im Doping, Zitat, völlig uneffektiv, weil wir eine Mischsportart haben, eine technisch-taktische Komponente haben. Der Spieler wäre mit Dummheit gestraft, würde er versuchen, sich darüber zu optimieren. Er würde sich sicherlich nachher in der Leistung eher verschlechtern.
Ja, ähnliche Komponente. Ich hatte das gestern auf Twitter schonmal gemacht, die typische Argumentationskurve, die einem immer begegnet ist. Du wirst ungefähr die Reihenfolge erst mal, es gibt überhaupt nicht Doping im Fußball. Dann der nächste Schritt, wenn das irgendwie nicht ganz dran kommt vorbei, dann wusste der Sportler davon nichts. Falls dann klar mit der Sportler wusste es irgendwie doch, dann war es auf jeden Fall ein Einzelfall. Und dann das beliebteste Argument, das wir eben auch schon durchgekaut haben, war damals. Warum ist es in einer anderen Zeit in diesem Leben jetzt in einer aktuellen Generation? Jetzt gibt es das nicht mehr.
Warum ist das so? Ist das so, weil einfach der Fußball des Deutschen liebstes Kind ist und wir alle eigentlich viel lieber, ich meine, wir wollen ja vielleicht auch lieber an Helmut Rahm denken, wie er aus dem Hintergrund schießt und nicht an irgendwelche Spritzen in der Kabine. Ist das der Grund, warum auch solche Reaktionen auch einfach durchgehen? Also es wird ja nicht öffentlich wirklich kritisiert.
Ja, ich finde es gar nicht so einfach zu beantworten. Ich habe ein bisschen darüber nachgedacht, wie die Entwicklung damals im Radsport war, weil wir vorher genau dasselbe Phänomen hatten, gerade in der ARD, in dem ja sogar die ARD Jan Ullrich Geld gezahlt hat, mit richtig hohen Summen und Werbeverträge abgeschlossen hat und sowas. Und da war es selbst in dem Moment, wo es eskaliert ist, hat es ja immer noch ein halbes Jahr mindestens gedauert, bis irgendwann Klartext gesprochen wurde, auch von TV-Seite aus. Wenn man die Kommentatoren – ich kenne die jetzt so ein bisschen vom Radsport – sieht, dann trauern die immer noch dem nach, was damals passiert ist. Sie würden am liebsten immer noch jeden Sommer in Frankreich das erleben, was sie sonst erlebt haben. Und im Fußball sind wir noch nicht so weit, dass der Schritt zwangsweise gehen musste. Ich glaube, da kommt man tatsächlich erst raus, wenn es den großen gegenwärtigen Fall gibt. Und ich weiß noch nicht mehr, ob da Fuentes für ausreichen würde. Da müssten wir jetzt schon langsam die Bombe platzen lassen, damit die Spieler auch noch aktiv sind und man davon sprechen kann. Dann hättest du plötzlich so Leute wie Xabi, Alonso, die jetzt bei Bayern München dazu spielen und dann kommt was über denen raus. Dann ist irgendwie was möglich. Aber ich glaube, solange immer nur nach und nach immer wieder vereinzelt, in entfernten Ländern untere liegen und so ein paar Sachen öffentlich werden, ändert sich an dem Konstrukt erstmal nichts.
Was ich immer ganz interessant finde, ist, gerade wenn es um das Argument geht, Doping würde ja nichts bringen oder jetzt auch dann quasi – also es gibt quasi die körperliche Argumentation, die scholl fährt. Also Doping bringt nichts, weil wenn du dir einen Prozentpunkt mehr Kondition gibst, dann hast du einen Prozentpunkt weniger Technik, sage ich jetzt mal so, wie in einem Computerspiel. Und dann gibt es die strukturelle, sportstrukturelle Argumentation von Robin Dutt jetzt beispielsweise, der eben sagt, es macht deshalb keinen Sinn, weil eben auch ganz viel Taktik und Technik im Fußball eine Rolle spielt. Das heißt, es wird ständig gesagt, es würde ja gar nichts bringen, die Leistung zu steigern. Und gleichzeitig feiern wir uns alle ja aber dafür ab, wie toll sich der Fußball entwickelt hat. Wenn wir jetzt mal von den 70ern bis jetzt in die Gegenwart gucken, ist er viel dynamischer geworden. Die Spieler laufen zwölf bis 13 Kilometer. Das heißt, das Training hat sich definitiv verändert und da hat doch eine Leistungssteigerung stattgefunden.
Ich meine, die Spieler laufen mindestens doppelt so viel. Und sie müssen viel öfter sprinten als damals. Plus das ganze Körper, andere körperlichen Faktoren, die auch dazu kommen. Und ich finde, wenn wir jetzt vielleicht an dem Punkt sind, wo man die ganze Vergangenheit sich anschaut, wie sehr dort immer schon Sachen bekannt geworden sind im Nachhinein, und das bis in die heutige Generation rein nimmt, kann man sich auch die Frage stellen, warum sollte sich denn gegenwärtig irgendwas verändert haben, wenn die Personen von damals jetzt irgendwo noch im Sport aktiv sind und vielleicht genau die Vorbildfunktion auch einnehmen für die gegenwärtigen Sportler und dort die Konstrukte in den Mannschaften geschaffen haben und das Ganze zusammenspielen. Es gab ja überhaupt keinen Anlass für einen Reinigungsprozess in irgendeiner Form, und den kannst du ja nur von außen durch einen Anstoß geben. Und, ja, kein und. Den Punkt habe ich schon gesetzt.
Vielleicht abschließend möchte ich noch kurz einen Kommentar aus der SZ vorlesen. Ich glaube, vom Donnerstag war die Ausgabe, ja doch, von heute. Ich habe es nur gestern runtergeladen, von Claudio Catuogno. Der hat geschrieben als Reaktion auf die These von Robin Dutt. Wer domt, wird schlechter. Diese These ist so abenteuerlich, dass sie die Frage aufwerfen würde, wer hier tatsächlich mit Dummheit gestraft ist. Würde die These nicht gerade von vielen nachweislich klugen Vertretern des Fußballbetriebs auf allen Kanälen unters Volk gebracht? Das legt eher den Schluss nahe, dass hier jemand für dumm verkauft werden soll, der es doch längst besser weiß. Das Fußballpublikum. Das ist vielleicht der entscheidende Punkt, dass wir zwei, und vielleicht auch die Hörer, die sich so einen Podcast anhören, vielleicht eher die Minderheit sind der Fußballinteressierten. Wir interessieren uns für solche Hintergründe, und die breite Masse möchte dann eigentlich doch gar nicht genau wissen, was da war. Gut, jetzt lass uns dann nochmal von diesem aktuellen Fall ein bisschen wegkommen. Wir haben jetzt über die Rolle der Medien ein bisschen geredet. Ich finde, dass Mehmet Scholl einen ganz interessanten Punkt kurz angesprochen hat, über den wir noch nicht geredet haben. Er hat auf die vermeintlich vielen Dopingkontrollen verwiesen, die er hatte. Lass uns da nochmal ganz kurz sprechen, wie funktionieren eigentlich Dopingkontrollen?
Ja, ich kann ja mal erzählen, ich habe vor anderthalb Jahren ungefähr mal eine Dopingkontrolle begleitet beim Bundesligaspiel in Nürnberg. Gegner habe ich schon wieder vergessen, warum auch immer. Ich bin eigentlich total fußballinteressiert. Das kommt wahrscheinlich ganz anders rüber. Ich bin sogar Fan von einer Mannschaft, von Borussia Dortmund, über die ich heute schon negativ gesprochen habe. Das nur zur Einordnung. Ich schaue mir sogar sehr viele Spiele an, die mir auch noch wirklich Spaß machen. Aber auf jeden Fall habe ich in Nürnberg damals ein Spiel begleitet unter strenger Aufsicht vom DFB, also Rainer Koch vom DFB, der Vizepräsident. Als Journalist für Spiegel Online gibt es auch eine Reportage darüber, die ich später noch geschrieben habe. Der Ablauf ist im Prinzip so. Man muss unterscheiden zwischen Trinkskontrolle und Wettkampfkontrolle. Jetzt erstmal die Wettkampfkontrolle. Du hast in drei Bundesligastadien jedes Wochenende eine Kontrolle. Eine Kontrolle heißt, dass aus jeder Mannschaft zwei Spieler kontrolliert werden. Das wird vorher ausgelost und erst kurzfristig bekannt gegeben. Ich glaube, gefühlt innerhalb der letzten 24 Stunden vor Anpfiff, aber eigentlich ein bisschen näher dran am Anpfiff, sodass jede Mannschaft offiziell erstmal einen Raum vorbereiten muss, weil sie theoretisch eine Kontrolle erwarten können. Sie erfahren dann eigentlich erst vom Anpfiff, ob ein Kontrolleur kommt oder nicht. Das ist die Reihenfolge erstmal. Dann läuft es so an, dass du einen verantwortlichen Kontrollarzt hast, der sich dann in meiner Regel noch ein bis zwei Helfer dazuholt. Die versammeln sich da, besprechen jeweils mit einem Mannschaftsverantwortlichen, das ist oft der Teamarzt, kann aber auch irgendjemand anderes mit der Befugnis sein, treffen die sich vorher und sprechen kurz alles nochmal den Ablauf ab. Dann gibt es Chaparrons seit einigen Jahren, also seit dem Fall von der TSG Hoffenheim, wo es die Situation gab, dass die Spieler erst sehr spät zur Dopingkontrolle gekommen sind. Seitdem wurden die Chaparrons verpflichtet und eingeführt. Das sind sozusagen die Personen, die nach Abpfiff die Spieler in die Kabine begleiten. Die stehen am Anfang auch dabei, werden kurz gebrieft, denen wird gesagt, du bist heute für die Mannschaft zuständig, für die Heimmannschaft, du achtest auf die Spieler der auswärts Mannschaft. Dann läuft das Spiel, in der Halbzeitpause trifft man sich wieder, und die Mannschaftsverantwortlichen, die beiden, ziehen dann Nummern aus einem Säckchen, wo sie nicht reinschauen können, und das sind die Spieler, die dann kontrolliert werden sollen nach Anpfiff. Allerdings sehen sie in dem Moment noch nicht, welche Spieler das sind, sondern sie greifen nur zu und packen das dann in einem anderen verschlossenen Beutel und überlegen, habe ich zu einem Punkt vergessen, es werden immer noch zwei zusätzliche Spieler jeweils gezogen, falls dem einen tatsächlich mal passieren sollte, dass er sich so schlimm verletzt, dass er auf dem Platz sich nicht mehr bewegt oder ins Krankenhaus um einen Helikopter transportiert werden muss. Also in diesen Maximalfällen kann man dann noch eine Probe entkommen, was jetzt gar nicht so einfach ist. Und dann gibt es so einen Moment, ich glaube, das ist eine Viertelstunde vor Abpfiff, wo dann noch mal veröffentlicht wird, welche Spieler sozusagen heute kontrolliert werden müssen. Das stehen dann die Chaperons auch dabei und die gehen dann an das Spielfeldrand warten. Dann haben sie die Aufgabe, die ganze Zeit, die Spieler, die kontrolliert werden sollen, die beiden im Auge zu behalten und mit dem Abpfiff sie dann auch möglichst nicht mehr aus dem Auge zu verlieren. Und von dort in den Doping-Kontrollraum zu begleiten, was gar nicht so einfach ist. Da gibt es auch einige Anekdoten, die man da beobachten kann. Kann ich jedem mal empfehlen, wenn man regelmäßig in den Stadion geht, zu schauen, wer eigentlich so Chaperon im Stadion ist. Das sind nicht selten Fans vom eigenen Verein, immer Geschichtsrichter oder Leute, die einfach sympathisieren mit dem Verein.
Grüße an Ed Lisas Welt, der auch schon als Chaperon unterwegs war, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe von den Kolinas.
Ist das der Schiedsrichter, der dort spricht? Ich habe heute zum ersten Mal den Podcast gehört. Beim Leben fand ich ganz klasse, geht allerdings drei Stunden, so wie unser heute hier fast. Und da hat er das, glaube ich, auch kurz erwähnt gehabt. Ja, genau, okay. Da habe ich wieder was gelernt. Und genau, dann kann er das bitte in einer Sonderungssendung auch noch mal gerne aus seiner Perspektive erzählen. Ich finde das ja total spannend. Wenn ihr einen Kontrollraum begleitet, dann ist es die Herausforderung für die Spieler, irgendwie Urin produzieren zu können. Und auch gar nicht so wenig. Da gibt es eine Mindestmenge, ich habe nicht mehr im Kopf, 50 Milliliter vielleicht, die sie sozusagen dann abgeben müssen. Du hast dann einfach einen Schrank mit Getränken und trinkst dann so lange, bis es irgendwie funktioniert. Es gibt ja auch immer wieder Geschichten, dass dann ungefähr vier, fünf Stunden da sitzen, wenn es überläuft, wenn sie zu aufgeregt sind oder was weiß ich. Und dann gibst du deine Urinprobe ab. Eine Urinprobe läuft so, dass du tatsächlich dann in den Raum rein begleitet wirst und dir genau geschaut wird, dass du dann nicht irgendwie was manipulierst. Und das wird dann auf zwei Becher verteilt und versiegelt das dann selber, damit du alles irgendwie auch klarst, nicht der Arzt hat irgendwie was unsauber gemacht oder so, sondern ich habe das als Spieler unter Kontrolle und es ist versiegelt, wird abgegeben. Seit dieser Saison gibt es auch Blutkontrollen in der Bundesliga im Wettkampf. Die gab es sogar nicht, dadurch gibt es dann quasi noch ein bisschen aufwendigeres Prozedere, wobei das schnell geht, nur einmal kurz pieksen und dann hat man das Blut. Das ist eigentlich einfacher als Jeroinkontrolle. Und wenn die Kontrollen dann zusammen sind, wird es gekühlt und einem Transportdienst gegeben. Der Transportdienst fährt zum Doping-Labor, das ist in Köln oder Greisha in Deutschland. Dort werden die Proben analysiert und dann gibt es einen gewissen Zeitraum, bis wann das passiert sein muss. Da habe ich jetzt auch die ganzen Zahlen nicht mehr im Kopf, aber das ist für Blut und Urin unterschiedlich zwischen 7 und 14 Tagen. Dann gibt es ein Ergebnis und das alles anonymisiert ab dem Zeitpunkt. Das ist nun eine Idee, die man später wieder zuordnen kann. Die Ergebnisse werden dann automatisch vom Labor aus an die DINADA, also die Nationale Dopingagentur, und vor allen Dingen an den DFB gemeldet. Jetzt muss man wissen, dass das Besondere im Fußball ist, was nur an ein paar anderen Sportarten der Fall ist, dass der DFB zuständig ist für das sogenannte Ergebnismanagement. Das bedeutet, der DFB bestimmt erst mal, was dann passiert. Die DINADA ist auch informiert, wenn es eine positive Probe gibt, aber das ist wichtiger, das muss man mit dem Kopf behalten, der DFB entscheidet, was der nächste Schritt ist. Im DFB läuft es so, dass es dann einen kleinen Kreis gibt, das ist dann vor allen Dingen wieder Rainer Koch, die darüber erfahren, ob es eine positive Probe gibt, und dann können sie entscheiden, ob sie den nächsten Schritt innerhalb des Hauses zur Anti-Doping-Kommission geben. Und die Anti-Doping-Kommission würde dann entscheiden, was machen wir mit dieser Person, wie gehen wir damit um.
Und warum dürfen die das entscheiden? Das muss doch unstrittig sein.
Ja, das ist einer meiner großen Kritikpunkte. Der DFB hat sich dieses Konstrukt geschaffen, weil sie gleichzeitig – das ist der zweite große Kritikpunkt – der Geldgeber sind für die Kontrollen. Also normalerweise ist es so, das ist in fast allen anderen Sportarten so, dass die NADA ein gewisses Budget pro Jahr hat, sich das auf die Sportarten aufteilt und dadurch bestimmt, wie viel kontrollieren wir in ihrem Sport. Im Fußball funktioniert das so, dass der DFB komplett die Kontrollen bezahlt, also auch die Kontrollen, die die NADA durchführt. Und dadurch, dass sie entscheiden können, wie viel Geld wir investieren, können sie natürlich auch entscheiden, wie viele Proben überhaupt stattfinden. Das ist sozusagen das eine. Sie können die Menge bestimmen und sie können auch danach den Ablauf bestimmen. Wobei man sagen muss, die NADA erfährt auch davon, wenn es eine positive Probe gibt. Das hat sich ja von erklärt, es gibt etwas zur NADA und zum DFB. Allerdings können sie sich erst in dem Moment melden, wo der DFB die NADA darüber informiert, wie sie mit der positiven Probe umgehen. Sie haben die Möglichkeit, ein Vetorecht einzulegen und theoretisch auch ein Verfahren einzuleiten. Das gab es aber noch nie in der Geschichte.
Ok, kurz noch, die NADA ist die nationale Anti-Doping-Aktur. Wir wollen später noch mal ein bisschen über die Institution reden. Lass mich jetzt mal kurz zusammenfassen. Wir haben jetzt die Wettkampfkontrollen und du hast gesagt, es werden in drei Bundesligastadien an einem Spieltag jeweils zwei Spieler von jedem Team kontrolliert. Das heißt, wir haben zwölf kontrollierte Spiele.
Ja, genau. In der zweiten Bundesliga ist das selbe Verhältnis.
Von ja insgesamt 324, wenn ich jetzt nicht… Also ich glaube, man stellt ja einen 18-Mann-Kader. Ok, hältst du das für eine… Wie ist diese Quote im Vergleich zu anderen Sportarten? Ist die hoch, ist die normal?
Also ich finde, in absoluten Zahlen gemessen sind das schon ganz schön viele Kontrollen, die sie da leisten müssen, ja. Aber im Verhältnis, wenn man schaut, wie groß ist eigentlich das ganze Fußball, wie viele Spiele stecken dahinter, dann ist das eine ziemlich geringe Zahl. Wobei mein Kritikpunkt noch nicht mal ist, dass das im Wettkampf unbedingt zu wenig ist, weil du… Also wenn das so funktioniert, wie es kommuniziert wird, dass jeder irgendwie bereitstehen sollte, dass es eine Kontrolle geben könnte, dann ist immerhin schon mal so ein bisschen der Zeitraum vorm Spiel abgedeckt, dass du nicht direkt irgendwie vorher noch was machen kannst. Du weißt natürlich mit Anpfiftern spätestens heute, wer ich nicht kontrolliere oder wer könnte kontrolliert werden. Ja, ach, da kann man… Ich finde es insgesamt zu wenig, aber ich finde, viel schärfer sind dann die Trainingskontrollen. Oder hattest du jetzt zum Wettkampf erstmal noch eine Rückfrage?
Nein, Wettkampf ist eigentlich klar. Wenn mich mein Taschenrechner nicht belügt, dann sind es 3, 7 Prozent an eingesetzten Spieler oder im Kader stehenden Spieler, die pro Spieltag kontrolliert werden, mathematisch gesehen. Aber dann lass uns zu den Trainingskontrollen kommen, weil da bin ich sehr gespannt, wie es da ist.
Genau. Im Training muss man immer unterscheiden zwischen Nationalspielern, die gehören sozusagen zu der Gruppe der besonders gefährdeten Sportler, heißt in der Nader-Definition, und den anderen Spielern. Ich meine mit Nationalspielern nur die deutschen Nationalspieler. Bei der nationalen Adypink-Agentur kann man nur für die eigenen Nationalspieler zuständig sein. Bei der normalen Alltagsspieler kann nur im Mannschaftstraining kontrolliert werden. Der wird nicht zu Hause getestet. Also du hast schon mal einen sehr berechenbaren Zeitraum, wann bei dir jemand zur Kontrolle theoretisch vorbeikommen kann. Bei den Nationalspielern ist es anders. Bei denen gibt es dieses Prinzip, das man von anderen Sportlern auch kennt, dass es theoretisch einen kleinen Zeitraum gibt, in der Nacht, wo keiner klingeln darf. Aber sonst kann es sein, dass bei dir jemand vor der Haustür steht und du bist meldepflichtig. Du musst in das sogenannte Adams-System eintragen, wo du jeden Tag unterwegs bist. Was ich aus der Praxis gehört habe, machen das die Nationalspieler nicht selber. Sie sprechen eher mit dem Rater und schicken dort eine SMS, wo man so unterwegs ist. Und der muss dann mal pflegen, dass man auch nicht irgendwie die Kontrolleure bei einem vor der Haus stehen und man selber nicht da. Weil dann tritt der Fall ein, dass es einen sogenannten Mist-Test gibt. Und wenn du dreimal innerhalb von zwei Jahren, glaube ich, so einen Test bekommen hast, das gab es im Handballgrad, im Prominentenfall mit dem Krause oder Kraus, dann gilt das wie ein Dopingfall sozusagen. Also ein Dopingvergehen. Dann kannst du gesperrt werden. Und beim Training läuft es dann auch so ab, dass es Urin- und Blutproben gibt. Da kann man nicht so pauschal sagen, wie viele Spieler dann bei so einer Kontrolle wirklich kontrolliert werden. Da muss man sich dann die Gesamtzahlen anschauen. Das wäre vielleicht ganz schlecht, wenn ich die jetzt mal nennen könnte. Ich kann die mal nebenbei raussuchen.
Das heißt aber quasi, wenn man so einfach nur mal die Zeiträume anguckt, in denen eine Kontrolle möglich ist, dann ist das für jeden, der nicht Nationalspieler ist, nur während eines Bundesligas oder auch Zweitligaspiels und während des Trainings oder im Umfeld des Trainings.
Und zu der Quote, ich hatte mal so eine Wahrscheinlichkeit im Ländervergleich ausgerechnet, dass ein Fußballer aus der ersten oder zweiten Liga, wie oft der durchschnittlich pro Jahr kontrolliert wird, da habe ich FIFA und UEFA, das sind quasi nochmal Special-Geschichten, nicht mit reingerechnet. Und in Spanien lag die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass bei eins, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, du bist einmal pro Jahr durchschnittlich kontrolliert, Deutschland bei 1, 2 und Italien bei 2, 2. Vergleicht Türkei zum Beispiel bei 1, 15, also auch irgendwie oben bei den Ligen mit dabei. Und wenn man jetzt mal schaut, wer ganz unten war, Schweiz zum Beispiel 0, 14, Tschechien 0, 07, Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du einmal pro Jahr irgendwie durch deine nationalen Kontrollinstanzen kontrolliert wirst.
Und dann muss man ja jetzt, wenn man jetzt dann so ungefähr sich vorstellen kann, was ist so die Wahrscheinlichkeit, mal kontrolliert zu werden, da muss man ja noch wissen, wie wirken denn die verschiedenen Dopingmittel? Also ist das jetzt so wie Alkohol, der sich innerhalb von 24 Stunden mit 0, 1 Promille pro Stunde absetzt, so im Durchschnitt, kann man das für die einzelnen Wirkstoffe grob sagen? Über welche Zeiträume reden wir da?
Ja, es ist wirklich komplett unterschiedlich. Und vor allem kann man das auch nicht pro Substanz sagen, sondern auch immer die Art der Dosierung und der Methode spielt eine Rolle. Man kennt es aus anderen Sportarten, dass die Mikrodosierung beim Doping mal eine große Rolle spielt, weil du viel mehr in der Lage bist, sehr exakt zu bestimmen, wie viel du dir zuführst und dadurch auch Grenzen erkennen kannst. Es gibt ja Sportarten, wo du so einen sogenannten Blutpass hast, und dann dürfen deine Blutwerte bestimmte Grenzen nicht überschreiten und kannst ziemlich genau dich an die Grenze randopen und so solche Geschichten. Ich denke, sowas wird im Fußball auch passieren. Aber das ist ein bisschen schwierig zu sagen. Wenn du jetzt so das klassische EPO nimmst, dann könntest du das nicht direkt vor dem Wettkampf nehmen, wenn dann wirklich auch auf EPO die Probe analysiert wird. Es sei denn, du nimmst – es gibt mittlerweile zig verschiedene EPO-Möglichkeiten, und du arbeitest mit ganz neuen Möglichkeiten. Dann gibt es noch dazu – das macht es auch nochmal schwierig – die Möglichkeit, nochmal andere Dopingmittel zusätzlich zu nehmen, die wiederum dazu dienen sollen, das eigentliche Dopingmittel zu verschleiern. Da gibt es auch viele Klassiker. So hast du halt verschiedene Kombinationen. Aber grundsätzlich – darauf zielt ja die Frage nicht ums hinaus – kann man sagen, dass gerade im Training, in so bestimmten Phasen, wo du nochmal in der Lage sein möchtest, dir zusätzlich Austausch und Muskraft anzutunieren, also außerhalb des Wettkampfes, du dann auch die meiste Zeit hast, wenn die Wahrscheinlichkeit sinkt, dass du in der Zeit auch kontrolliert wirst.
Und es gibt ja durchaus Doping, was jetzt nicht nur so wirkt wie Aufputschmittel, wo du vorhin schon als Beispiel genannt hast mit 15 aufputschende Minuten. Ich meine, da weiß ich ja dann gut, das könnte ich dann nur zum Spiel nehmen und dann ist aber auch die Gefahr, dass ich kontrolliert werde. Aber es gibt ja Doping mit langfristigen Effekten, wo das durchaus auch Sinn machen kann. Ich sage jetzt einfach mal, im Sommer das Risiko, das etwas geringere Risiko getestet zu werden, einzugehen. Und das wirkt sich dann trotzdem noch im Laufe der Saison aus.
Genau, nehmen wir mal ein Beispiel Eigenblut-Doping zum Beispiel. Das ist also das, was rund um Fuentes praktiziert wurde. Das ist eine Sache, die tatsächlich auch gegen Gärtner nicht nachweisbar ist. Du musst quasi auf frischer Tat abtappt werden oder in den Blutbord, da müssen wir noch irgendwo rumliegen. Und die Sache wirkt sich tatsächlich über zwei bis drei Tage aus. Also da kannst du, gerade wenn man vor ganz großen Turnieren schaut, Weltmeisterschaften zum Beispiel, da war es in den letzten Jahren immer so, dass es immer so einen großen Generaltest gab für alle Mannschaften, also immer an unterschiedlichen Tagen, wo dann die ganze Mannschaft mal kontrolliert wurde. Und wenn du den einmal überstanden hattest, konntest du ziemlich sicher sein, dass du erstmal nicht mehr kontrolliert wirst, außer die Nader reißt irgendwie ins sonst wo entfernte Land und pickt dich dann nochmal heraus. Da hast du eigentlich einen ziemlich berechenbaren Zeitraum gehabt, wo du irgendwie was machen konntest. Ich wollte noch einen Punkt kurz loswerden, bevor ich den komplett vergesse. Man muss auch noch unterscheiden, deshalb weiß ich nicht, ob ich den Punkt gerade schon deutlich gemacht habe. Im Training die Kontrollen immer Nader. Also die Leute, die dahin kommen, sind von der Nader beauftragt. Und Wettkampf bislang immer, das wird sich nach dem Sommer ändern, der DFB selbst. Also da kommen nun DFB-beauftragte Ärzte hin, die dort kontrollieren. Das ist jetzt auch nicht unbedingt ein Argument für Unabhängigkeit. Es gibt jetzt allerdings für dieses Jahr einen neuen Anti-Doping-Code von der Welt Anti-Doping-Agentur, also WADA, und darin steht, dass alle Sportdaten jetzt umstellen müssen, dass tatsächlich die nationalen Kontrollinstanzen dann auch im Wettkampf kontrollieren. Deswegen verkauft der DFB das gerade bis zur SPR-Maßnahme, dass sie jetzt noch unabhängiger werden wollen, aber sie sind verpflichtet dazu, dass sie dann quasi ab Sommer die NADA komplett unterwegs ist. Und jetzt nochmal zum Argument davor. Natürlich bestimmt der DFB aber weiterhin, wie viel Code die NADA dafür bekommt. Und gerade im Wettkampf ist es extrem aufwendig für die NADA und auch für eine finanzielle Belastung, da so umfangreich kontrollieren zu können, wie der DFB das vielleicht in dem eigenen Netzwerk jetzt machen konnte in der Vergangenheit. Da bin ich sehr gespannt, auf wie viele Kontrollen die da pro Jahr kommen werden. Gerade wenn du im Wettkampf von der ersten Liga bis zur Regionalliga im Wettkampf kontrollen und dann noch sowas wie bei A-Junioren und Frauenbundeskrieger und so und DFB-Pokal. Und darunter ist nur ganz, ganz, ganz vereinzelt und allein das Liga-Netzwerk abzudecken.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen. Da werde ich später auch nochmal kurz darüber reden, über welche Summen wir da eigentlich auch sprechen. Wir haben ja vorhin schon angesprochen, dass es schon Drucksituationen gibt, mit denen sich erklären ließe, dass man zu Topien greift. Und ein Aspekt, den du vorhin auch selber genannt hast, sind auf aufgetretene Verletzungen, z.B.
Wie sieht es denn mit Kontrollen im Reha-Betrieb aus bei verletzten Spielern?
Du meinst richtig in Krankenhäusern oder einfach nur in der Zeit, wo der Spieler verletzt ist?
Das gelten die selben Wahrscheinlichkeiten, die wir jetzt gerade schon durchgeskizziert haben, also einfach sozusagen die Trainingszeit. Die Frage finde ich spannend, die kann ich im einen oder anderen Fall gar nicht beantworten. Wenn der Spieler jetzt ganz entfernt irgendwo seinen Reha-Betrieb durchgeht, dann kann ich schon das beantworten, dann sinkt die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass er dann auch kontrolliert wird für einen nationalen Kontrollinstanz. Wenn ein Spieler seinen Arzt hat, der im Ausland irgendwo tätig ist, kann sein, dass irgendwer ihm hinterherreißt oder wenn er Nationalspieler ist, dann auch dort in dem Land von seiner Instanz kontrolliert wird. Aber du bist viel schwieriger zu erreichen. Die Phase an sich ist aber natürlich total interessant. Du möchtest ja möglichst schnell wieder auf dem Platz stehen. Gerade Muskelaufbau, wenn du lange verletzt bist, auch deine konditionelle Aufbau, dann bringt es dir enorm was, wenn du dir da noch einen zusätzlichen Schub geben kannst.
Und du bist natürlich sowieso in einer Situation, wo du Medikamente zu dir nehmen musst und auch Behandlungsmethoden über dich ergeben lässt. Da rutscht man dann vielleicht auch leichter rein, ohne das jetzt verharmlosen zu wollen. Welche Rolle spielen denn Schmerzmittel an dem Punkt? Geht das als Doping?
Ne, also die normalen Schmerzmittel, da gibt es eine große Diskussion darüber. Es gibt mehrere Forscher, die sagen, eigentlich müssten wir Schmerzmittel als Doping gelten, weil einfach auch die Hemmschwelle komplett sinkt, wenn ich viele Schmerzmittel zu mir nehme und es ja auch unterschiedliche Dosierungen von Schmerzmitteln gibt. Aber grundsätzlich gilt erstmal Schmerzmittel, kein Doping. Es gibt dazu aber sehr spannende Studien. Seitens der FIFA selbst, also tatsächlich in dem Fall auch mal von dem eigenen Verband und WM 2010, ich weiß nicht, ob das mittlerweile schon Aktuellere gibt, aber da war es so, dass die FIFA eine Umfrage gemacht hat, also die hatten den Zugriff sozusagen auf die medizinischen Daten, was die Spieler dann wirklich alles so bekommen haben und da war der Ergebnis, dass 60 Prozent der Spieler während des WM-Turniers mindestens einmal zu Schmerzmitteln gegriffen haben und 40 Prozent der Spieler vor jedem Spiel Schmerzmittel genommen haben. Und das von wirklich oft wie zähler Seite, das sind keine Zahlen, die irgendwie hochgedreht wurden. Das ist ein akutes Problem auf jeden Fall im Leistungssport, besonders im Fußball und besonders in den Phasen, wo du am Ende der Saison stehst. Ich nehme da am liebsten mal das Beispiel Bastian Schweinsteiger, wenn man sieht, wie der in den letzten Jahren immer irgendwie es noch durch die Turniere geschafft hat, durch seine großen Highlights in seiner Karriere, die in der Regel am Ende der Saison stattfinden. Und danach dann verletzt war und erst mal kaputt am Boden lag für ein paar Monate manchmal. Dann sieht man schon, da kann man erahnen, was er vorher alles mit seinem Körper angestellt hat.
Aber Schmerzmittel ist jetzt quasi kein sportjuristisches Problem, sondern eher ein medizinisches, dass man sagt, es ist nicht gesund, seinen Körper quasi die natürlich gegebenen Schmerzgrenzen zu nehmen und dadurch Raubbau am eigenen Körper zu betreiben. Das ist quasi das Argument gegen Schmerzmittel. Gut, und gleichzeitig freuen wir uns alle natürlich daran, dass, wenn du jetzt schon Schweinsteiger ansprichst, eben jener im WM-Finale nach jedem Trip nochmal aufsteht. Ja, das ist eine zwiespätige Sache, aber sehr interessante Zahlen und wahrscheinlich dann auch die häufigste Form der Medikamenteneinnahme im Profisport und auch im Fußball. Jetzt fällt ja generell auf, wenn ich mir das Kreuzband reißen würde – dreimal voll ist gekloppt, dass das nicht passiert, während ich hier am Computer sitze. Wenn ich mir das Kreuzband reiße, dann bin ich ein paar Monate außer Gefecht, und zwar viele Monate. Wenn sich ein Profisportler das Kreuzband reißt, dann sind die manchmal erstaunlich früh wieder zurück. Wie lässt sich das erklären? Ist es einfach nur, weil sie den Zugriff auf die bestmöglichen Ärzte haben, oder gibt es da auch Vermutungen, dass in dem Bereich auch Doping oder Behandlungsmethoden in der Grauzone eine Rolle spielen?
Da bin ich mir ganz sicher, weil das ein wesentlicher Aspekt ist. Wie früh kannst du wieder auf dem Platz stehen, kommst du schnell wieder in eine Mannschaft rein, der ganze Konkurrenzdruck. Da gibt es natürlich Erklärungen, warum man versucht, das Maximum zu gehen. Du bist eh schon medizinisch behandelt, wie du es vorhin schon gesagt hast. Der Übergang ist gar nicht mehr so groß, um dann noch etwas anderes zu bekommen. Viele Spieler lassen sich mit Spritzen behandeln. Also von der Wohlfahrt weiß man, dass er immer sehr auf schnelles Spritzen setzt. Ich bin mir sicher, dass viele nicht komplett aufgeklärt werden oder auch nicht aufgeklärt sein wollen, was sie am Ende in dem Moment alles bekommen. Dir geht es dann darum als Spieler, wann der Arzt in zwei Wochen wieder auf dem Platz bringt. Oder soll ich da auf meinen Körper hören und mehrere Monate warten? Ich habe mich mit Bundesliga-Ärzten schon darüber unterhalten. Man hört auch von deren Seite aus, dass die ja selber auch ein Problem zum Teil mit haben. Das gilt nicht für jeden. Ich glaube, ein paar Leute haben es auch nicht so im Gedanken. Aber die Ärzte haben natürlich auch einen Druck, dass geschaut wird, wie schnell kriegt unser Arzt in der Mannschaft die Leute wieder auf den Platz? Und wie sieht das in anderen Vereinen aus? Wenn wir da immer irgendwie scheinbar nach derselben diagnostizierten Verletzung zwei, drei Wochen mehr brauchen, ist das schon komisch. Vielleicht sollten wir uns mal umschauen, ob es so wen anders gibt. Das spielt eine totale Rolle.
Du hast jetzt Miller-Wolfart angesprochen. Vielleicht können wir über ihn noch ein paar Worte verlieren. Er steht ja auch deshalb im Fokus, weil wir hier genau diesen Fall haben, dass Pep Guardiola ganz offensichtlich, zumindest laut des Buches, das über ihn erschienen ist, sehr unzufrieden ist mit der Art und Weise, wie bei den Bayern mit den Spieler behandelt werden. Und jetzt im Fall Thiago ist das ja auch eskaliert und er ist zu spanischen Ärzten gegangen. Wie ist denn die Person Müller-Wolfard einzuschätzen, jetzt aus der Sicht, aus der du arbeitest?
Ja, wir haben uns mit Müller-Wolfard auch schon ausführlich auseinandergesetzt, auch seinem Anwalt, als wir zuletzt schon berichtet haben. Aber es ist nichts passiert, nur ein paar Drohungen. Ich finde es einerseits extrem faszinierend zu beobachten, was Müller-Wolfard alles so auslösen kann in der Bundesliga, wie alle möglichen Sportler aus aller Welt, aber auch gerade im Fußballbereich, aus der ganzen Liga zu ihm hinreisen. Ich finde es auch interessant, wie Mannschaften es zulassen, dass ein Arzt so viel Bescheid über die wichtigsten Spieler in der Bundesliga weiß, obwohl er für einen Konkurrenzverein zuständig ist. Dazu ist Müller-Wolfard auch in der Nationalmannschaft, schon seit Jahren einer der maßgeblichen Ärzte. Müller-Wolfard selber niemand, der operiert, aber jemand, der die Diagnosen stellt und einfach gerne spritzt. Dazu verwendet er noch vor allen Dingen dieses eine Mittel, das man von ihm kennt, weil er auch gerne darüber spricht. Aktobe-Gin, Mittel, wo es auch – es stand zwischendurch mal auf der Dopingliste – ganz kontroverse Diskussionen gibt, was es jetzt auswirkt. Vielleicht auch nur Placebo. Da gehört man ganz unterschiedlicher Meinung zu. Ich finde es bemerkenswert, wie viele Spieler diesem einen Arzt vertrauen. Das ist so gegen mein Grundverständnis, dass es so eine Person geben kann, die alles kann und da wirklich der absolute Beste drin ist. Daran glaube ich einfach nicht. Ich kann mir das nur so erklären, dass sich das in den Jahren über solche Vertrauensgespräche, Empfehlungen entwickelt hat. Er hat da seine Methoden, womit er schnell Leute wieder auf den Platz bringt. Das ist ja das, was dann weitergegeben wird. Er hat mich wieder fit gemacht, ich war schon bei allen anderen, da hat es irgendwie nicht funktioniert, aber jetzt konnte ich da wieder laufen. Und damit hat er Erfolg. Der Kritikpunkt von Guardiola ist ja vor allen Dingen, wenn ich das richtig sehe, dass er sich einen Arzt wünscht, der an seinem Platz einfach vor Ort ist. Wohlfahrt selbst hat ja seine große Klinik in München im Zentrum. Das ist einfach ein Weg, so kennt er das nicht aus der Vergangenheit. Du hast normalerweise deine Leute, die wenn jemand auf den Platz umknickt, die dann auch wirklich die Fachmänner sind, um das Diagnostizieren zu können. Jetzt hat das Müller-Wohlfahrt ja geschickt gelöst, indem sein Sohn, den er da immer schon ausgebildet hat, der sozusagen der Vorortarzt ist beim FC Bayern, wenn ich die letzte Berichterstattung so richtig mitbekommen habe. Also Kilian Müller-Wohlfahrt. Und dadurch werden wir uns noch lange, viele Jahrzehnte wahrscheinlich mit dem Thema Müller-Wohlfahrt auseinandersetzen können, was ich eigentlich wieder ganz nett finde. Ich finde die Entwicklung bei Bayern gerade ganz charmant. Kann man sich mit dem Thema noch ein bisschen länger auseinandersetzen.
Und jetzt, also bei Dr. Müller-Wohlfahrt, nur um quasi alle Hörer mit ins Boot zu holen, da gehen Sportler ein und aus. Also nicht nur eigentlich alle deutschen Nationalspieler und großen Bundesliga-Stars, sondern auch Juselm Boll, glaube ich, war bei ihm. Und so in der Kategorie Sportler ist er.
Und nicht nur Sportler, sondern auch Promis. Also die ganzen Bayern von Stoiber über sonst wenige. Das sind auch regelmäßig Praxisbesucher, also auch eher sehr enge. Das Machtnetzwerk in München ist auch vertraut mit ihm. Und dazu auch so Leute wie Bono, der extra angereist kommt. Das hat er schon clever aufgebaut.
Das heißt quasi, ich will jetzt, sollte hier irgendein anderer zuhören, ich möchte überhaupt nicht sagen, Müller-Wohlfahrt ist wie Fuentes, aber er hat sich ein ähnliches Netzwerk aufgebaut, allein an Klienten, die ein- und ausgehen in der Praxis. Also wir haben hier wieder so einen Arzt, bei dem es sich zentriert.
Genau, und vielleicht ist es da besser mit der deutschen Geschichte, einen vorsichtigen Vergleich anzustellen. Früher war das halt in Deutschland Klümper. Zu Klümper sind auch wirklich alle möglichen Menschen hingereist. Ich habe schon selbst so Leute, um mal einen Namen zu nennen, Fritz Sörgel. Fritz Sörgel ist quasi einer, der jetzt immer wieder angerufen wird als Dopingkritiker. Ein Chemiker, der in Nürnberg wohnt. Und der sitzt auch in dieser Untersuchungskommission, der Dopingvergangenheit in Freiburg aufarbeitet. Und selbst der sagt, ich war früher auch… Man ist halt zu Klümper gefahren, wenn man irgendwie nicht mehr weiter wusste. Und so hörst du das so breit. Und das Phänomen ist erstmal das gleiche bei Müller-Wulfert. Die haben sich so ein bisschen abgelöst. Müller-Wulfert hatte irgendwann auch mal gesagt im Spiegelinterview, dass er dabei… also richtig rumformiert. Der Spiegel hat ihm gesagt, er hätte ja mal gesagt, dass er bei Klümper auch gelernt hat. Und dann hat Müller-Wulfert das bejaht. Ich bin vorsichtig geworden in den Formulierungen bei Müller-Wulfert.
Mayo Mai, gut. Lass uns mal noch vielleicht kurz zumindest auf einen Aspekt kommen, den wir jetzt komplett am Rand gelassen haben. Einfach nur, weil das auch zum Thema Doping im Fußball gehört. Du hast gesagt, wir haben Kontrollen von der Erstliga bis runter zur Regionalliga und darunter nur punktuell. Gibt es Erkenntnisse darüber, welche Rolle Doping im Amateursport spielt?
Also es gibt Leute, die sich damit beschäftigt haben. Aber meistens gibt es jetzt nicht die große, allumfassende Studie, dass man da wirklich groß mit Zahlen hantieren kann. Was aber da immer so rauskommt, ist, das können die Leute, die selber regelmäßig kicken, wahrscheinlich sogar noch viel besser bewerten als ich, weil ich nie im Verein gespielt habe. Aber ich kenne das nur, wenn Gespräche mit Leuten im Verein sind und durch solche Leute sich damit beschäftigt haben. Dass du schon in so einem Bereich hast, wo Schmerzmittel wirklich auch extrem sind. Also alle Leute, die ich kenne im Verein, haben immer wieder Situationen, wo sie sich auch vor dem Spiel präventiv Schmerzmittel zwischendurch reinziehen. Und dann so Einstiegs-Doping, würde ich das mal nennen, was schon auf der Dopingliste steht, was einem aber schon mal helfen kann. Es gibt da den einen, der sich viel damit beschäftigt hat mit Doping im Fitnessstudio, aber in Verbindung auch mit Leuten, die gleichzeitig im Fußballverein sind. Da kamen viele raus, Stimulanzchen, Koffeinzeug, MDMA und solche Sachen, die von den Fitnessstudio-Regeln gerne in die Liegen mit reingetragen wurden. Vielleicht kann man das auch sehen, was Asthma-Spray in anderen Sportarten ist. Wenn man das einstiegt, dass man das auch besser eratmen kann, dann sind das vielleicht die ersten Stimulanzchen, die man zu sich nimmt. Ich glaube, dass das ziemlich verbreitet ist. Ich würde mich aber freuen, wenn man das etwas härter und tiefer bekommen würde.
Jetzt bringt mich das eigentlich dann auch gleich zu dem Punkt, über den ich auch noch ganz gerne mit dir reden wollte, nämlich die Institutionen, die hier eine Rolle spielen. Denn der Amateursport liegt dem DFB laut eigener Aussage sehr am Herzen. Und jetzt habe ich von dir schon erfahren, der DFB ist der wesentliche oder der Geldgeber für die nationale Antidopikagentur. Da müsste doch eigentlich dem DFB auch daran liegen, auch im Amateursport Kontrollen durchzuführen.
Ja, es wird vereinzelt auch getan. Man muss nur schauen, dass die Zuständigkeiten dann auch zum Teil auf die Landesverbände einfach übertragen werden. Die Landesverbände hätten auch die Möglichkeit zu kontrollieren, aber es ist natürlich auch echt ein finanzieller Aufwand. Also muss man sich schauen, wir verlieren unterschiedlich viele Verbände. Der DFB hat auch garantiert genug Geld, um da noch tiefer und mehr zu machen. Dafür machen sie einfach einen zu fetten Umsatz jedes Jahr. Bei den Landesverbänden kenne ich mich mit den Zahlen gar nicht aus, was für die möglich wäre. Ich glaube, wenn es da mal so eine umfassende Studie zu geben würde und man die Fakten auf dem Tisch hat, das ist das Problem, dann würde da auch nochmal mehr passieren. Solange hat man da erstmal keinen Anlass, was ja schon irgendwie darum geht, den eigenen Profisport erstmal reinzuhalten. Aber vielleicht die Vergleichszahlen, die ganz interessant sind. Ich hatte mal so eine Umfrage bei den ganzen 15 Nationen ungefähr gemacht in Europa, wie das so mit Dopingfällen aussieht und anderen Parametern. Und in Portugal – ich glaube, das war für die letzten 10 Jahre – habe ich abgefragt, wie viele Dopingfälle es gab. In Portugal kam die Zahl heraus, dass es 103 Dopingfälle, also offiziell bestätigte Dopingfälle, in den letzten etwa 10 Jahren gab in Portugal. Ich habe mich da ein bisschen länger mit denen unterhalten, und die kontrollieren deutlich tiefer. Dadurch haben die tatsächlich dann auch diese Ausschläge. Im Vergleich dazu übrigens in Italien, in dem denselben Zeitraum, gab es 56 Dopingfälle, die schon mal so zusammengefasst sind. In Frankreich 42, in Deutschland ist es ein bisschen tiefer. Noch mal kurz ein paar Fakten, warum Fußball gedoppt wird.
Bei welcher Summe reden wir jetzt, wenn es darum geht, dass der DFB die NADA finanziert? Du hast schon angedeutet, dass es teuer ist. Du hast auch gerade gesagt, dass sich die Landesverbände zum Beispiel das gar nicht leisten könnten. Kann man sagen, wie viel eine Dopingkontrolle kostet? Oder ein Rahmen, was die NADA an Geld zur Verfügung hat?
Ich suche gerade, wenn du Lust hast, eine Anekdote im Kopf hast, kannst du das überbrücken. Ich suche mir gerade mal die aktuellen Zahlen.
Mit den Anekdoten ist das schwierig. Aber ich muss sagen, dass ich einen wahnsinnigen Respekt davor habe, dass du allein alles, was du mir jetzt erzählt hast, im groben Kopf hast. Ich komme allein mit den Namen immer wieder durcheinander. Es wurden auch bei Twitter einige Namen uns genannt. Über die meisten haben wir schon gesprochen. An dieser Stelle auch schon mal herzlichen Dank für all das Feedback, was wir bekommen haben.
Und dir noch mal Danke für die Brücke. Ich habe jetzt die alten Zahlen, die galten sozusagen bis Anfang der letzten, zu Beginn dieser Saison, da wurde noch mal ein bisschen aufgestockt. Da wurde gesagt von der DFB-Seite aus, dass sie der Nahe 800.000 Euro pro Jahr geben. Davor waren es 700.000 Euro insgesamt für Wettkampf und Training, in den Antidopingkampf investieren. Im Verhältnis, wenn man schaut, was für eine Summe der Deutsche Fußballbund und jedes Jahr welche Bilanzen präsentiert werden, ist das wirklich ein ganz kleiner Prozentteil. Das heißt, dass ungefähr, könnte man sagen, 2014 so ungefähr 500 Kontrollen kontinuierlich machen im Training. Das ist so die Zahl, mit der man gut kalkulieren kann. Kann man dann runterrechnen, was das bedeutet? Wir haben ja vorhin schon so ein bisschen gesagt, die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist nicht besonders hoch.
Okay, und vielleicht um das ins Vergleich zu setzen. Ich habe gerade gefunden, 25, 7 Millionen Euro hat der Deutsche Fußballbund allein bei der WM an Prämien erhalten.
Das ist eine Ansage.
Da sind jetzt nur die WM-Prämien und noch nichts anderes. Das nur mal im Vergleich zu den 800.000. Und woher kommt jetzt dieses, ich sage mal in Anführungszeichen, spannende Konstrukt, dass der Verband sich, also die eigene Kontrolle finanziert? Ist das unüblich oder ist das üblich im Sport?
Das ist üblich in den Sportarten, die ein bisschen Kohle haben. Das ist einfach historisch erst mal bedingt. Der DFB ist ja unabhängiges Organ, ist da nicht zu verpflichtet. Solange du nicht gezwungen wirst, durch sowas wie die Regularien von der Weltanzubring-Agentur, gibt es erst mal keinen Grund, das zu ändern. Die anderen Sportarten freuen sich darüber, dass sie sich nicht mitfinanzieren müssen. Allein geht es dann schon in die NADA, wobei es auch ein paar andere Sportarten gibt, wo die Kontrollen zwar von der NADA durchgeführt werden, aber dann dieses Ergebnismanagement, was ich noch fast viel wichtiger finde, dann wieder beim Verband liegt. Gibt es auch nicht so viele, findet man aber alles auf der Webseite von der NADA, wenn man sich das mal intensiver anschauen möchte. Im Tennis ist zum Beispiel auch so ein Fall, wo das Ergebnismanagement beim Verband liegt.
Das ist schon ein wunderbares Wort Ergebnismanagement. Ich musste gerade ganz kurz wieder eine halbe Stunde zurückspulen, um mir überhaupt vor Augen zu führen, dass es darum geht, was passiert mit dem Ergebnis der Doping-Tests, was passiert dann. Wer darf da was machen? In dem Zuge hast du ja dann auch schon Rainer Koch angesprochen, und ich glaube, das Wort Anti-Doping-Kommission ist auch schon kurz gefallen. Willst du mir noch kurz erklären, was hat es damit auf sich?
Genau, es gibt beim DFB diverse Kommissionen, und für Doping-Bereich sind besonders zwei Kommissionen interessant. Die sportmedizinische Kommission, die entscheidet immer mehr so um grundsätzliche medizinische Fragen und für die Doping-Geschichte ist dann die Anti-Doping-Kommission interessant. Die Kommission ist dafür zuständig, über die Doping-Sperren zu entscheiden. Das ist sozusagen das Gremium, was dann das Urteil spricht, den Spieler anhört und so die ganzen Geschichten. Wie gesagt, diese Vorstufe ist wichtig, dass aber erstmal in der Regel das Büro von Rainer Koch mit seinen zwei Mitarbeitern darüber fährt und er entscheidet, ab welchem Moment er die Antidoping-Kommission einbindet.
Und er ist Vorsitzender der Kommission und gleichzeitig sitzt er auch im DFB-Präsidenten.
Genau, er ist Jurist, Vizepräsident, also der ist schon gut verdrahtet. Der würde selbst das jetzt auch nicht so beschreiben, wie ich es gerade mache, aber ich habe mich mit dem länger unterhalten, als wir uns letztes Mal in Nürnberg getroffen haben. Da hat er es mir auch deutlich gegenüber gesagt. Erstmal reden die da und dann kommt die Anti-Doping-Kommission. So und jetzt ist es ja immer interessant, wer sitzen solchen da drin? Jetzt schaue ich mal, ob ich die Aktuellliste habe. Hast du die gerade geöffnet? Ich sage so ein paar, die ich im Kopf habe, dann kannst du ja vielleicht ein bisschen ergänzen. Also drin sitzt auf jeden Fall der Tim Mayer, das ist unser Haupt-Nationalmannschaftsarzt mittlerweile. Also Nuller Wohlfahrt ist ja mehr ein Hintergrund. Gurt Spand ist auf jeden Fall der Name.
Moment mal, ganz kurz nochmal. Da sitzt der aktuelle Nationalmannschaftsarzt mit drin. Genau. Und wird diese Kommission auch über gedobte Nationalspieler entscheiden? Okay, keine weiteren Fragen.
Der auch noch drin sitzt ist der ehemalige Arzt der Nationalmannschaft, Wilfried Kindermann. Da gab es auch eine Frage bei Twitter oder eine Bitte, dass wir doch solche Leute nochmal ins Gespräch bringen. Der ist aufgetaucht im Zug, also diverse Male in der Vergangenheit mit sehr provokanten Äußerungen zur Dopingfreigabe. Da schadet doch das Medikament nicht. Und da war vor allen Dingen, soweit ich es richtig im Kopf habe, rund um diese – es gab ja die letzte große Berichterstattungswelle rund um Fußballdoping war, als dieser Bericht zur Dopingvergangenheit in Westdorfschland veröffentlicht wurde. Das ist jetzt schon wieder ein paar Monate her. Da ist er auch aufgetaucht als jemand, der einfach so seine Erfahrung mit diversen Spritzen gesammelt hat. Also er hat auch nicht so den dopingfreiesten Ruf. Der sitzt doch auch mit unserer Kommission. Seien wir das mittlerweile ausgeschieden? Oder siehst du ihn bei dir auch noch in der Liste? Nein, der ist noch mit dabei. Und jetzt musst du mir helfen und ich google mal parallel die Liste, damit ich die auch vor Augen habe.
Ich habe sie dir sogar geschickt. Wir haben noch Dr. Toni Graf Baumann mit in der Kommission sitzen.
Der sagt mir gar nichts. Ich kann wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr so viel sagen. Das waren die, die ich sofort vor Augen habe. Ich gucke nochmal rüber.
Dann haben wir natürlich eine Quotenfrau. Das war jetzt total unfair der Frau gegenüber. Aber wir haben noch eine Frau in der Doping-Kommission, Dr. Astrid Maria Offer aus Köln. Genau. Und dann haben wir noch Dr. Stefan Schmidt aus Frankfurt, Dr. Karl-Heinrich Dittmar, der ist auch Vertreter des Liga-Verbandes. Da können wir vielleicht gleich noch drüber reden, wie die drin hängen. Und Andreas Nagel, der einzige Nicht-Doktor oder Professor in der Kommission.
Genau, aber du hast einen interessanten Punkt gelehnt. Auch Andreas Nagel ist ein Vertreter vom Liga-Verband. Das war ja das, was du mit dem Thema gerade angedeutet hast. Du hast eine extrem enge Verzahnung von den eigenen Interessen. Also die DFL ist auch nochmal kräftig mit vertreten. Das sind, glaube ich, die zwei dauerhaften Sitze, die immer zustehen in der Kommission. Das Präsidium ist in irgendeiner Form drin. Dann hast du die ehemaligen aktuellen Ärzte. Also da sieht man, warum es gut wäre, ein unabhängiges Gremium zu haben und nicht innerhalb des Verbandes.
Unabhängiger als das? Also bitte, Jonathan. Okay, erklär mir nochmal kurz, wie ist denn da überhaupt das Zusammenspiel zwischen DFL und DFB? Ich hätte ja zum Beispiel eigentlich gedacht, dass die Wettkampfkontrollen, wenn wir von der Bundesliga reden, von der DFL organisiert werden müssten, weil es ja deren Wettbewerb ist.
Ja, aber darüber steht dann sozusagen immer noch der DFB, der für den ganzen Profibereich letztendlich zuständig ist. Also das ist das einzige Zusammenhang ist wirklich, dass es halt diese festgelegten Mitglieder gibt. Aber sonst ist das obere Gremium im Fußball, das ist ja auch in allen anderen, wenn man sich so die anderen Kommissionen im DFB anschaut, ist ja überall dasselbe Spielchen. Also wenn es darum geht, was für Strafen werden jetzt ausgesprochen, wenn jetzt irgendwie es die Fans sich daneben genommen haben oder Strafen gegen Spieler, Wettkampf, Sperren, wenn ich das jetzt nicht komplett falsch sehe, werden auch über die DFB-Kommissionen ausgesprochen, oder? Ja genau, also das ist überall dasselbe Gebilde. Der DFL ist ja quasi nur ein ausgelagerter Bereich vom DFB meines Erachtens.
Der DFB als Verband, der oben drüber drohend hat, da die Entscheidungshoheit. Okay, und kann man so generell eine Aussage treffen, wie sich der DFB zu Doping im Fußball positioniert hat und hat sich das irgendwie in den letzten Jahrzehnten verändert?
Ich glaube, es hat sich insofern verändert, dass sie öfter einfach mal drüber sprechen. Also allein auf der Webseite kommt schon immer mal wieder so ein Interview, was sie da machen und so. Und jetzt kommt hier irgendwie in den letzten zwei Jahren einfach bei den Kontrollen immer mal wieder so ein bisschen was passiert. Da wurden jetzt irgendwie Blutkontrollen damit eingeführt, im Wettkampf jetzt macht die Nadel einen Wettkampf und so Sachen, sowas immer mal wieder zu kommunizieren hatten. So grundsätzlich sehe ich jetzt keine große Veränderung, seitdem ich mich irgendwie damit beschäftige. Wir merken das persönlich daran, dass uns Rainer Koch auch immer gern kontaktiert. Ich hatte schon öfters die Situation, dass wenn wir immer was gemacht haben und wir den DFB eine Konfrontation geschickt haben oder so, dass das dann Rainer Koch bei mir anruft und dann nochmal so nachfragt.
In welcher Stimmungslage?
Dann extrem freundlich. Einfach nur, habe ich denn alle Informationen, wollen ja nichts zerbergen, extrem transparent sein, vertuschen nichts und so. Das nehme ich ihm auch alles ab dann in dem Moment. Aber ich finde es interessant, dass er in der Vizepräsidentin direkt anruft, wenn man nur eine Nachfrage gestellt hat. Der DFB kümmert sich dann schon persönlich um einen.
Gut, aber kann man natürlich auch extrem positiv sein.
Ich finde das in dem Moment tatsächlich gut. Ich kann dann auch noch mal meine Nachfragen stellen, loswerden. Und am Telefon antworte ich natürlich auch ein bisschen spontaner und anders, als wenn ich das alles nur per E-Mail mit der Presseabteilung machen muss. Und beim DFB, also alle, die in dem Bereich journalistisch unterwegs waren, das ist ja ein Konstrukt, wo es nicht einfach ist, an bestimmte Personen ranzukommen. Da bin ich dankbar, wenn man bestimmte Schnittstellen hat, wo man auch mal direkt die Handynummer wählen kann vom oberen Funktionär.
Und der DFB hat die Anti-Doping-Kommission und finanziert die NADA. Das heißt, der DFB wird jetzt nicht die Mehmet Scholl-These vertreten, Doping im Fußball gibt es nicht.
So nicht. Der DFB vertrete die Position, wir haben kein Doping-Problem. So vielleicht. Aber es gibt natürlich immer wieder schwarze Schafe, wo mal was passiert, wobei dann sagen, wenn man sich die Fälle anschaut, dann sind es meistens aber schon so Sachen, da ist mal jemand auf einer Party drüber hängen geblieben. Wo man auch sagen muss, wenn man die deutschen Doping-Fälle anguckt, sind es tatsächlich immer wieder solche Fälle, die auftreten. Aber mein Grundprinzip wäre mehr Gründe, warum es die anderen Fälle nicht gibt, und solche Sachen dann aufzuliegen. Ich merke, dass mein Glas Wasser alle ist, aber ich glaube, ich packe das jetzt bis zum Ende. Falls man die Stunden verloren geht, müssen wir mal schauen.
Wir kommen ja auch langsam, aber sicher aus Ende. Ich würde es nur noch so drei Stunden ansetzen, was wir jetzt noch zu besprechen haben. Ein Spaß beiseite. Ich denke, wir sind ja auch wirklich so langsam am Ende angelangt. Du musst mir bitte nur noch eine Sache jetzt noch erklären. Wir haben jetzt die nationale Antidopikagentur und wir haben die Weltantidopikagentur, also NADA und VADA. Von der NADA weiß ich jetzt, die finanziert sich oder wird finanziert über den DFB. Wie ist es mit der VADA?
Die VADA wird im Prinzip über das Olympische Komitee finanziert, also das IOC.
Also im Prinzip dasselbe Konstrukt zwischen Verband, der eine Institution dafür bezahlt, sich selbst testen zu lassen.
Genau, ein bisschen komplizierter, weil es ja darum ganz viele Sportarten in unterschiedlichen Ländern gibt. Aber du hast schon recht, das Grundprinzip ist genau das gleiche. Wobei die VADA, das sind ja nicht diejenigen, die am Ende die Kontrollen durchführen. Ich glaube, sie hätten die Möglichkeit, das zu machen, aber die Zuständigkeiten liegen dann immer bei den nationalen Tourneen. Die VADA ist das übergeordnete Gremium, was die Grundausrichtung bespricht. Große Fälle mit einschreiten kann, sie haben Widerspruchsmöglichkeiten. Es gibt ja immer wieder Fälle, die beim Internationalen Sportgerichtshof, beim Kass landen. Da ist die VADA teilweise auch ein Kläger, zum Beispiel als Fuentes thematisiert worden. Da war die VADA als Organisation auch mit Kläger, damit sie Zugang zu den Akten bekommen und solche Sachen. Deswegen gibt es dieses Konstrukt. Da kann man nochmal eine ganze eigene Sendung mitfüllen, warum die VADA auch so kritisch gesehen wird, aber das haben wir jetzt schon angedeutet. Vor der VADA war das IOC selbst zuständig für den ganzen Bereich. Falls du das eh durchspielen möchtest, aber wichtig an zusätzlichen Kontrollinstanzen, ist das alles, was international abspielt. Da kann man das einfach je nach Wettkampf direkt unterscheiden. Wenn wir uns in den UEFA-Wettbewerben bewegen, dann ist es die UEFA, die darüber entscheidet, wie und wie oft und wann kontrolliert wird. Und die FIFA dann genauso rund um die offiziellen Länderspieltermine und dann den großen Zeitraum um die tatsächlichen Turniere. Das vielleicht noch mal kurz an der Weltmeisterschaft skizziert. Da gibt es auch ein spannendes Konstrukt, weil es eine Übergangsphase gibt, wann die Zuständigkeit der nationalen Verbände aufhört bei den Kontrollen und wann die FIFA zuständig ist. Da gibt es einen definierten Zeitraum. Ich glaube, bei der Weltmeisterschaft beginnt das ungefähr sechs Wochen vorher. Ab da legen dann die FIFA-Kontrolleure auch los. Dann gibt es immer noch die Möglichkeit, dass die nationalen Ampeter-Doping-Aventuren irgendwohin reisen und Tests machen. Das kennt man auch von der Nationalmannschaft, dass in den Trainingslagern immer mal wieder kommt. Heute gab es Doping-Kontrollen. Aber sonst ist die FIFA dann offiziell zuständig in dem definierten Zeitraum. Und gerade im Wettbewerb sind es nur die Verbände kontrollieren lassen. Da wird gar kein unabhängiges Tränenraum angelassen.
Jonathan, wir haben echt viel besprochen. Ich versuche noch mal so einen ganz kurzen Abriss zu machen, und dann hätte ich noch eine größer gefasste Schlussfrage an dich. Wir haben jetzt wirklich sehr ausführlich – und ich danke dir schon mal wirklich sehr herzlich für die viele Zeit und die vielen Infos über Doping im Fußball geredet. Ich denke, das Argument Doping im Fußball bringt nichts, konnten wir zu Genüge widerlegen oder zumindest sehr in Frage stellen. Es gibt viele Formen, die Doping im Fußball haben kann, und wir haben dann beim Blick in die Geschichte des Fußballdopings auch festgestellt. Man kann auch belegen, dass diese Formen auch schon alle angewandt wurden. Und anhand des jetzt zufällig gerade stattgefundenen Bekanntwerdens des Dopings beim VfB Stuttgart und SC Freiburg konnten wir auch ganz gut so ein bisschen abklopfen, wie schwierig da die Rolle der Medien ist. Weil sie eben einfach sehr tief drin hängen an den Aktiven und auch ein Interesse an positiven Geschichten haben und weniger negativen. Das heißt, dass und gleichzeitig wahrscheinlich auch die Masse der Fußballfans gar nicht so sehr interessiert ist an diesen negativen Folgen. Wir haben festgestellt, dass Schmerzmittel eine große Rolle spielen, aber es ist nicht als Doping zu bezeichnen. Und dazu gibt es aber auch Studien von der FIFA. Das fand ich sehr interessant mit den 40 Prozent der Spieler, die vor jedem Spiel erstmal was einwerfen. Das zeigt vielleicht auch ganz gut, in welchem Medikamentenumfeld sich Fußballprofis bewegen. Und wir haben noch einen kurzen Schlenkerer gemacht über die Methoden des Müller Wohlfahrt bis hin zum Amateursport. Eigentlich Wahnsinn, dass wir diese Kurve noch hingekriegt haben, wo nur noch sehr punktuell kontrolliert wird und wo sich der DFB dann vielleicht gar nicht mehr so zuständig fühlt. Und das führt so ein bisschen zu meiner Schlussfrage, auf die man dann doch am Ende irgendwie immer stößt. Und man kann jetzt für oder gegen Doping sein. Es gibt ja auch durchaus Leute, die dafür sind. Was gibt es denn rein medizintechnisch gesehen für Folgen von Doping? Ist es immer gesundheitsgefährdend, kann man das so sagen? Und müsste man deshalb gegen Doping sein?
Grundsätzlich ist der Leistungssport erstmal gesundheitsgefährdend. In jedem Leistungssport werden Sachen vom Körper verlangt, die er in der Lage ist, nicht zu erfüllen. Du kannst nicht mit einem normalen Körper, ohne dass er Schaden nimmt, bis zu 90 Spiele in der Saison überstehen, wo er Vollgas geben muss. Beim Doping ist das Problem, dass du deinen Körper über deine Leistungsgrenze hinaus noch weiter überforderst. Du ignorierst im Moment die Warnsignale von deinem Körper und spürst sie vielleicht auch gar nicht mehr. Das schadet dem Körper noch mehr. Es gibt sicherlich Dopingmittel, wo der Schaden wirklich klein ist und wenn man es auch nur ganz punktuell macht, dann bleibt da nur noch das Grundproblem, dass der Sportleistungsschädigend ist, also der Profisport natürlich nur. Aber wenn man sich anschaut, wie es vielen Sportlern geht nach der Karriere, haben Dopingmittel oft keinen kleinen Anteil daran, dass der Körper so zerstört ist, wenn Sportler Probleme haben, aus dem Bett zu kommen und erst mal drei, vier Stunden brauchen müssen, bis sie die Treppe wieder runterlaufen können, oder solche Sachen. Wenn man jetzt die Extremen sieht, das ist das eine, wo man sehen kann, was passieren kann und noch extremer wird, wenn du jahrelang von Dopingsystemen begleitet wirst, wo du dann tatsächlich bis hin zu lebensgefährlichen Situationen entstehen können oder du in Abhängigkeiten entstehen, wo du nur noch mit bestimmten Geräten rumlaufen kannst. Das sieht man von – das Fass ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu groß, aber ich glaube punktuell ist das immer noch drin – von ehemaligen DDR-Sportlern. Also wenn man in Deutschland einen Verein für Doping-Opferhilfe, wenn man mit dem Verein spricht und da kommt man leicht mit ehemaligen Sportlern in Kontakt, dann ist das wirklich besorgniserregend. Das ist wirklich auch ein Motiv, warum ich es wichtig finde, darüber aufzuklären, weil es nun mal wirklich schädlich ist. Und wir kennen im Fußball auf viele Fälle von Herzinfarkten einfach im Spiel. Und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass ein gewisser Anteil damit auch mit Doping zu tun hat, warum der Körper in dem Moment dann einfach sich verabschiedet. Das kann man überhaupt nicht pauschal sagen. Aber so gibt es immer wieder, genauso wie du auch so einfach fertig sein kannst nach deiner Karriere, ohne Doping. Aber es gibt mit Sicherheit ziemlich große Schnittmengen. Und deswegen, um es grundsätzlich zu beantworten, ja, zu 99% extrem gesundheitsschädigend auf jeden Fall. Das ist aber ein negativer Ausstieg, jetzt, den du gewählt hast.
Wie kommt man denn positiv aus so einer Sendung aus? Hättest du einen positiven Ausstieg für mich, dann bitte. Ich meine, wir reden jetzt seit gefühlten acht Stunden darüber, was Leute mit ihrem Körper tun, aus einer Drucksituation heraus, an der wir alle auch nicht unbeteiligt sind als Zuschauer, als Fans, als Kunden der Bundesliga usw. Wir reden über Journalisten, die so tief in der Materie drinstecken, dass ihnen die Distanz in den wichtigen Momenten vielleicht ein bisschen fehlt. Wir reden über Institutionen, die sich selbst kontrollieren und das finanzieren. Ich weiß nicht, wie man da jetzt positiv herauskommt, vielleicht mit einem Witz.
Oh nee, das ist ganz schlecht.
Oder sag es mir, sehe ich es vielleicht auch einfach alles zu mir?
Nein, grundsätzlich sehe ich das alles genauso, habe ich ja klar gemacht. Mir geht es natürlich trotzdem so. Ich bin tatsächlich auch jemand, der sogar an die Tour de France schaut, nicht mehr so wie mit der Kindlichembegeisterung, die ich früher hatte. Aber ich bin tatsächlich gleichzeitig auch das Widersprüchliche. Feiere ich, wenn Borussia Dortmund jetzt aus der Krise rauskommt. Freue mich auch über jedes Tor. Da spiele ich das ganze Spiel mit und ich freue mich auch bei dem Spektakel, wenn so Spiele passieren, wo über 120 Minuten am Ende doch noch das Tor gelingt. Warum auch nicht? Die Kurve zum positiven Ausstieg ist so zu sagen. Der Sport kann trotzdem noch Spaß machen als Konsument und auch für den Sportler selbst. Du brauchst ja nicht jede Sekunde vor Augen für, was da passiert. Das sind die modernen Kladiatoren-Spiele und früher hatten sie auch…
Das finde ich jetzt aber ganz gut, dass du das noch ansprichst, weil das ist auch ein Vorwurf, der immer so inherent Journalisten wie dir gegenübergebracht wird. Erstens, du willst den Sport kaputt machen, zweitens, du erfreust dich ja eh nicht mehr dran. Du siehst nur das Negative und so ist es definitiv nämlich nicht. Sport ist einfach geil, aber wir haben auch gelernt, Sport ist auch Mord. Sport ist geiler Mord. Habe ich sogar den Sendungstikel. Jonathan, ich kann gar nicht in Worte fassen, wie dankbar ich dir bin, dass du dich auf diesem wilden Ritt durch Spritzen und Medikamente mit mir begeben hast. Auch ein Satz, den ich immer schon mal sagen wollte. Ich kann nur sagen, vielen lieben Dank, Jonathan Sachse, an alle da draußen besucht Fußballdoping.de. Ihr werdet wahrscheinlich während dieses Podcasts die Seite schon zum Einsturz gebracht haben. Und folgt diesem Mann bei Twitter, add Jonathan Sachse.
Genau, das ist richtig. Jetzt muss ich aber noch einmal Werbung für meinen Kollegen machen, den ich dreimal zu wenig genannt habe. Also mit Daniel Drepper mache ich das zusammen. Der ist auch der Gründer, der hat die ganze Idee. Deswegen bin ich überhaupt aufs Thema gekommen. Kann man auch ganz leicht auf Twitter folgen. Ich glaube einfach add Daniel Drepper bei mir, also add Jonathan Sachse. Und der ist gerade in Südafrika unterwegs, nicht auf Rechercherweise, um die Klümpere zu entdecken, der da mittlerweile wohnt, sondern einfach Urlaub machen. Der wäre sonst wahrscheinlich auch heute dabei gewesen. Aber den sollten wir nicht vergessen an der Stelle. Mir hat es auch sehr viel Spaß gemacht, heute so ausführlich darüber sprechen zu können mit dir.
Das freut mich. Und wie gesagt, alle, die sich für das Thema interessieren, folgt add Daniel Drepper und folgt add Jonathan Sachse. Und damit sind wir am Ende angelangt von unserem zweiten Tribünengespräch. Es freut mich sehr, dass ihr mitgehört habt. Bewertet uns sehr gerne bei iTunes. Wir freuen uns über positive Rezensionen, weil es hilft uns tatsächlich sehr, mehr Hörer zu gewinnen und wir freuen uns, wenn dieses Projekt mehr Hörer bekommt. Und ansonsten lege ich euch noch unsere Schlusskonferenz ans Herz, wo wir immer über den vergangenen Bundesligaspieltag reden. Nicht ganz so lang wie heute, auch nicht ganz so ernst wie heute. Vielleicht mal was leichtes zwischendurch. In diesem Sinne, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und bis zum nächsten Mal.